and as we get ready for the games we
must ask this great daily question which
is what has been your favorite moment
from the I am non-gm speed Chess
Championship and Anya
you've been along with me for the ride
everybody else you get involved with
hashtag speech s but what is your
favorite moment well there Ivana's have
been so many and I'm not just saying
that this this has been one highlight
after another the highlight reel for the
I am medicham could last two hours but
one thing that jumps to my mind is the
entire match between Danny wrench and
Teddy Coleman especially that final
segment hi I mean the adrenaline and
looking back just I was literally at the
edge of my seat that overtime it just
represents the competitive element in
the just the effort in the heart that
each and every player here has put into
it each and every match but there have
been many such incredibly successful
moments and I'm looking forward to
seeing what has stuck with the viewers
and Teddy's in the chat he said let's go
and one of them I would call my favorite
moment but a memorable moment for sure
is the stalemate between Eric Rosen and
Elizabeth Bates like she was up a queen
and he did this tricky thing
anticipating her pre-move Ryan getting
stalemated but we do have a match about
to get begin let's look at the Wyatt to
head match oh right yeah that thing the
head-to-head between John and Alina as
you can see on the graphic I mean John
has just been absolutely dominant he's
won his matches by 14 by 8 and then by 9
Alena should have close matches Krista
say lucky in the opening round she won
by two points then she was tied with
Eric before crushing him in the bullet
wins by five I think it steady of 17
have six and a half so I mean both these
players are you know trending upwards at
the right time indeed Elena has won all
of our matches by prime numbers that is
the extent of my knowledge and what I
offer to this commentary but yeah it's
important to point out that we've all
observes first match Alina played
against steel edge she was very very
close but you know it got into more and
more of a blow and Alina herself
pointing out that issue as she got her
feet under her and as she got more
experience and bullet she's only gotten
stronger so
like I said before you know an immovable
object meets an unstoppable force this
is gonna be fascinating and I was
reading the pre-match interviews with
the players we got to hear their
thoughts Lina saying she doesn't really
like to talk about her opposition before
playing and I understand that and we
have the game here JB gets the white
pieces as the higher rated in the blitz
type control so he gets white in this
first game and well look at John's
opening what do you make of this you
know Tori attack which he had played
against Bren yeah it's somewhat of a
cross between let's say London and the
Trump house key something a little bit
more sharp I think it has that slightly
sharper aura to it when compared to some
London positions but it's still very
positional Alena going t5 I think this
is the recommendation of some Kings
Indian books where black laces in
Grunfeld fashion basically arguing that
white spaces are slightly misplaced when
compared to regular Gruen fellows and
see three play just to show up the
centre so unlike a grünfeld where
there's no C pawn there's an e pawn used
on e4 rather than a c3 it's going to be
harder to break down the pawn chain
because of this goes b2 c3 to d4 rather
than just c3 to d4 as when the nice get
treated on c3 Negrin field so alina said
initially she wasn't going to watch
John's match against Greg then in her
interview she said you know I kind of
had to so I did actually I shouldn't
watch it live but she watched it after
the fact and so she she must have seen
his games against Craig she knows that
John is the type of player who likes
this Tory attack from the white side but
early on Donnie I know it's early very
early but for a time situation this is a
substantial lead in the clock for Lina
that is true and you know we've noticed
that even the time situation that
transpires and let's say the first 10 15
moves of the game that has very very
significant bearing on not only abbey
game proceeds but the time the dynamic
of the time situation that we see in the
first couple games of the match that can
be kind of hard to erase and it can be
hard to reinvent yourself in the course
of imagining here we see John really
going into the tank he's almost a minute
down I think he's trying to decide where
and
even if to develop the bishop he does
the bumps into c4 wonderful Lina's main
ideas here is maybe she could move that
night from d5 and then follow up with c5
that central break can basically free
black from any obligations in the centre
but both of them have pretty tough
positional problems here to solve a lot
of choices in terms of how to put the
pieces and what are those choices is is
that going to play pawn to g5 at some
point which is a big committal move but
does kick the bishop of course your
knight on d5 is under attack so you're
gonna move that first but I'm just
trying to think bigger picture do I want
to bring my knife from d7 to b6 which
attacks the fluency for wall
protecting night or are the Knights just
going to be clumsy stepping on each
other's toes and that loses the access
that's c5 coastal she plays c6 in a very
solid fashion but this Bishop h4
painting the pawn Isom is really
bothering me because I would love to
play e5 but of course I can't because
that's a poetess gambit yeah I mean
you're right you don't want to
procrastinate it - I mean me saying you
don't want to procrastinate too much
with anything would be incredibly
hypocritical but I mean this the early
in the sense of the position with
deciding how you want to play in the
center alena playing f5 so very concrete
obviously the positional weaknesses of
this move need no explanation but she's
threatening to just win John special
with g5 and at poor and even if John
plays h3 Elina has that tricky move f4
it's actually surprisingly difficult to
save that bishop you know looking pretty
trapped ok h3 but John is definitely
orienting himself I think on some sort
of sacrifice I'm Chu five right so f4
you know that black is doing play g5
next but you've opened up more light
squares to attack so you played Bishop
d3 for instance g5 I'm sacking my bishop
on g5 taking back with the night and all
of a sudden there are good attacking
chances for white although the extra
material of course is in blacks favor
right and Alina is probably deciding
between going g5 I mean the f4 is
tempting but and she goes off for so she
is going for that Bishop and yeah I
think John is has several ways to you
know sort of orchestrate that sacrifice
the question is how do you want to
prepare it do you want to put the bishop
on g3 as you pointed out Robert or do
you want to play a general purpose move
such as rookie
one which he does okay please see five
quick listen even if her position
objectively is not great because of the
sacrifice I do like that she's playing
quickly and John responded rapidly as
well and the position like this down you
wear white the attack doesn't seem very
clearly where is the attack coming from
well because yeah one I was gonna say
you want lead Bishop III gets h7 but as
men enough six is a very good defender
well you want to realize that your White
has to be patient here um a lot of
people I think when they sacrifice a
piece they think that they're in you
know an urgent hurry they don't create
something within two moves the attack
will evaporate that's not quite the case
here remember John is two founds for the
peace and he does that some positional
compensation he could even consider I
know this sounds absurd at some point
putting a knight on e6 eliminating that
Bishop and basically going for a hybrid
of tactical compensation based on Lex
King in positional compensation based on
let's say the weakness of the seven pawn
and the weakness of blacks light sports
but for the time being I would bring all
the pieces and maybe clean up three
maybe rookie five something along those
lines and maybe Knights e4 to e5 and I
have three there we go I'm very nice I
liked Knight see for a little more just
because in it I go pretty exactly I had
a little more control of the age five
score and maybe that's not so important
because after Knight see for the queen
gets so come to age five but it's just
one of these things what I know exactly
where my knight belongs but to see
Foursquare for some reason felt a little
stronger but now that I come to e5 the
g6 square is white for the taking and I
really appreciate the point you made
Daniel that you were saying that people
feel this rush they need to act
immediately because if they hesitate for
even a second and don't go for a
checkmate then we I'm down a piece but
you have two pawns that's already good
material compensation but their
long-term weaknesses the g6 square the
e5 square the e6 square so even if I
play ninety six that we trade white
controls the light squares and this King
can still be in harm's way despite a
series of tricks exactly and you know
it's become very fashionable to say oh
I'm playing like alpha zero or this is
an alpha zero move I still can't wrap my
head around exactly what that means but
maybe part of it is you know alpha 0 is
showed that sometimes it'll sacrifice a
piece and not only will it do so for
purely positional reasons but it will
then lounge around on the
each four five ten moves as if nothing
has happened so it's really shown and
here by the way 95 there's this slide if
95 queen h5 that's checkmate after Queen
takes h5 and Bishop h7 check so a nice
time to show that there might be no time
to discuss alpha zero Lena's got to be
very careful here a lot of squares that
John is threatening to access Knight g6
I'm not sure about b5 I feel like that
neglected a little bit too much though
weaknesses on the Kings side and she
probably went b5 just to avoid any sort
of c4 kicking the night for the defense
the e7 square but you're right that
feels like you're playing on the wrong
side of the board you're not actually
helping your King and moves like 96
Bishop g6 are coming and actually this
this King looks like it's I mean it's
just doomed yeah this just looks
terrible mean Queen c2 Bishop h7 is an
immediate threat which I don't see a
defense - I mean there's tempting moves
such as Bishop d6 IG 6 but again Alina
just doesn't have any way to untangle
her pieces Queen sees you might be a not
the Queen see - there's Queen h5 so it's
not maybe first Bishop g6 and then Queen
c2 I'm trying to make this bishop h7
move work the Queen h5 idea is
surprisingly annoying so if you do leave
that square then queenship happens Queen
tribes not possible if you black a free
move because I would trade on h5 and
then there d7 Bishop is hanging so you
could play with like Bishop c2 if you
want to put the Queen first in the
diagonal you could play Bishop g6 of
course as you said just to kick the
Queen off you go by Knight to g6 which
traps the rook and puts pressure on e7
so if you want to gain your material
back you can at the very least for 96 to
take on that faith but Danya the clock
situation about a minute and 20 now for
John a minute 10 for Lina with a try oh
my god sorry Robert that's beautiful and
actually I see
dj''q wards at steady comer talks about
five it's not so clear up a bishop f7
Wow oh that's that is some beautiful
stuff and daddy had interrupt no Teddy
hadn't - Chad you were say JB going for
the safer route in a sense getting the
material back but I'm gonna show them
the analysis before that check Erika's
queen h5
please take my queen check and check me
so queen h5 was a nasty move
and honestly Jon's new bishop f7 I'm
gonna give myself license to uh to be a
little bit harsher I really don't like
that move even if you play queen d3 and
you stop Bishop at five I have no clue
why John gave away that Bishop and he's
is he better
absolutely he's much better but at least
the Lina's King is a little bit safe and
with fifty seconds on the clock for both
of them anything can happen Robert do
you share my my heart's view toward
toward that move I do and Quidditch five
maybe I'm the easiest thing to spot but
even if not for Queen each other as you
were suggesting like just getting the
material back probably isn't what John
wanted himself because you want to check
me and look at this night of fates
coming I black all of a sudden is
protecting her King side and if that's
the case then you know once White's
threats are parried black is gonna try
to strike back with midnight and Bishop
for the rook and ready dangerous yeah I
mean white is still obviously winning I
have no doubt that objectively it's it's
winning but John with 83 he's just he's
treading water a little bit too much
Lina getting her Knight to g6 Street
she's threatening Knight age four I
would play queen g4 you're with John
John but he's probably worried about hi
got three yeah and look at the clock
but down 95 yeah time is also an Alina
site and rook up six good move good
quick move and yeah each for this type
of thing you wanna do you wanna attack
it plays h5 giving him something g6
square but now she's striking back and
the thing is John's position has been so
stable since the very beginning of the
game oh but now the Knights come in at
500 but yeah that's a Knight takes d4
it's a very good recapture Knight f5
wins another exchange no not completely
over but it's a pretty easy position to
play at this point for white John can
gain some time with some semi prima by
maybe ninety six yeah but you know John
we definitely do man man man that
exchange sacrifice it looks good but me
and me and me and I'm not sure I should
do that and Queenie thinking off another
pawn ons colopsis early and I hear ya
this is this is it so he gets the job
done
I suppose he did although you know
there's still a little bit of rook t6
here it wins okay rookie singing
Alistair
you out in every position the safest 94
hands yep that'll do
yeah you just go over things b6 give
away your rook for the two nights and
then you easily win the ensuing end game
yo i was gonna say dunya then it felt
like john miss an opportunity earlier a
nice checkmate idea
so Alina and her first game it's Teddy
she made that Queen b6 with one of the
other potential favorite moments of the
I'm a gym SEC that Queen b6 move was a
shocker that end up helping her win that
game and eventually the match and John
an opportunity to start off with a bang
with queen h5 mm-hmm yeah that's an
interesting similarity John and I have
matching shirts you know matching Queen
sacrifices that didn't happen that's
various student commentary and
observations mr. Hess and I actually
like that we in our chat here we have
people of rooting for both players and
something like I don't know who to root
for other people saying go John and the
planes to go Alina it feels like it's
about 50/50 and you know this is I guess
what polls were made for I'm not sure if
I'm gonna do it but I am curious to see
where the fandom lies here but g4 played
by a little that he was actually some
trouble for John because after Bishop g6
there's h4 and I think Knight F to d7
there might hold on so there's a long
line right Mitch of g6 h4u certainly no
one above the H bun will bring up the
analysis board yeah so bishop g 6h 497
yes if h5 o but you take on d7 first and
then go age 5 uh-huh right I was about
to say I was trying to figure it out but
you take first and play h5
yeah then I realized what you were
saying was easy for h5 first 95 d5 Queen
d1 King D 1 castles Queens I would check
and your Bishop gets exactly but man
John I think John is thinking man named
Aaron because if he has to move an H fun
and allow Knight takes she's safe spell
at that Bishop d3 that sometimes happens
in these positions when you accidentally
lock your own Bishop in um this is big
big trouble for John and he goes head up
c7 but this one's a piece C I fell under
the same illusion
this night tasty 7 and h5 and that is a
piece that it's game over I mean there's
you can't even get any compensation so
you and John are just wearing the same
shirt we drinking the same coffee yes
and now playing the same let's say
letters sub-optimal moves and Alina sees
it Alina patiently thinking it through
and let's take a look at John's facial
expression it has not changed he shook
his head you see that oh there was a
little bit of a delay yeah he went oh
then shook his head this is no pain you
stunad slight slight nods with his head
as he used to alright guys this game
didn't go my way match is gonna be tied
proudly yeah let's take a drink my
coffee guys and good luck to Alina in
the next round and you know what's the
biggest problem with losing a game like
this Danya is that to move 12:00 and so
you then question not just your skills
or are you in good form in the day but
you question the opening even though
playing the Slav is no respect it
opening right but dammit wait should I
do something different because the slaw
didn't go my way and now uncertain so I
just think that this could have a deeper
impact than just this one game yeah I
agree and first of all those of you who
are you know surprised John has it
resigns that's very much sensible thing
to do I mean whenever there's so many
pieces on the board I know it sounds
strange but I would not resign here I
would make a couple more moves make
Elena show some technique because also
psychologically resigning on the 14th
over 13th move is just a tough thing to
swallow but I agree with you Robert I
mean that's you get that bad taste in
your mouth and and you do start
questioning your form when you blunder
in the opening in any game at least in
my you know in my case I always start
thinking well what if you know what if
I'm not as tactically sharp today maybe
maybe I need to triple check my lines
instead of double check I mean all those
doubts start to creep into your head and
they accumulate in the course of a match
they certainly do and John will play
this one on even though he's down min
and a half he's down a piece because he
also won the first game so Lina it
hasn't proven to herself that she can
win a game it's only one game and she
lost it and so I think it's a smart just
a psychological ploy to play on and
figure out you know is Alena in the
shape that she wants to be in if the
answer is yes then he will resign if she
just makes it less of a mess because the
king is still in Centanni one if the
King castles King side well that's sort
of ridiculous looking you're walking
into a potential attack you counts a
queen side can I steal a pawn can I
steal second poem yeah I don't exactly
see a clear-cut you know wait okay Elena
bloom very confidently but yes she has
the D file but to bonzes two pawns
so that's just my material there is some
compensation here for John but 90 for me
the problem is now Elena's king of safer
her pieces are coming to life and this
should be when Donnie and I are not all
saying that Alina has made any mistakes
because their position is completely
winning from an objective point of view
but then you start thinking about little
things here and there like can black the
Queen d5 next to throne Queen to eight
to white still has not proven that this
game is completely over just because
John is playing a little bit of
trickiness and here king b1 just
preemptively saying alright my king is
safer mm-hmm tucked closely to the
corner and I think it was good move in
also the time in vintage still huge for
her yeah and that King I mean white even
has ideas of white oh if black plays
like Queenie seven Bishop f4 white will
threaten Queen takes c6 Jack and John
trying to prevent that from happening
oh you are sly dog you
I think that's called a boat and there
is this boat and check maker at Samuel
Bowden 19th century player I think but
Alina I mean she doesn't even have to
rush here half three she can improve her
position but should be too I'm not in
thrall to the way that she's converting
this position I think Bishop d2 is
inaccurate
now John maybe gets his legs under him
with something like ninety six know if
you bend I can go to d4 excuse me like
v6 like you were saying d5 and we all
know John loves his knights on d5 is a
queen of four played there's going to be
a pin down the defiles yeah I think
that's a blunder actually yeah Michelle
sugar queen c3 double attack a5 so good
yeah
why once the a5 phone falls that's just
gonna be devastating and in the 97 is
pretty stuck because then the white
knight goes in the c5 which launches a
big attack mm-hmm we were kind of tries
trying to give everybody who you know
may not see why is this game over why
would you ever resign it's a good
question in fact a lot of coaches
recommend never to resign because you
can't win or draw a game when it's
already over and you've lost so now the
position is very difficult for black
because the king is King is weak on b8
this Knight is either coming in to d6 or
if your neck moves away to c5 I can
simply retreat my fish of the sea to and
you have problems down the D fund at
Bishop c2 here yeah just over is that
night because the Russians would say
yeah I mean this is takes well if you
take the Queen it's not as simple but
how do you do this Queen C 3 but now
Knight b6 and that lee hsien can
continue to make moves
the thing is she'll take twice and d8
and win the game 7 pawn yeah yeah yeah I
mean and then she also wins probably h6
and there's no not even an inkling of
Perpetual or anything like that
White's got too many pieces surrounding
her King that's right so it feels like
Jon's any chance that he thought he
might have had is running out but he
also knew for since move 12 that he was
gonna lose this game so it's not like
the end of the world yeah I mean losing
a peach like that with no compensation
and just one gone it's it's a little bit
too much to ask and and I've had this
argument with some students you know
about whether to resign at all because
some of them will say well one game out
of a million
I'll get stalemated my opponent will let
his guard down stalemate and it's
surprisingly hard to find a rational
kind of philosophical response to that
so I'm a late resigner myself you know
so I'm pretty sympathetic to it to
people who resigned late you're late
resigner got it
oh yeah I'm one of those Labor's eiders
I'm a pretty early resigner
so you know here is not a moment too
soon I would say because rook takes t7
is a big threat the knight can't move
because the rook kind of fate needs
defense the h6 pawn is following you 18
seconds left and counting down so it
would not be a moment too soon
if Jon would decide to do that and said
he plays on which I like I think well
let me ask you
does John have some desire to get rid of
the five-minute time portion and go to
these shorter time controls yeah yes
unequivocally absolutely yes would be my
response to that because first of all
Queen takes age six there's make C 5 so
Elena still has to you just can never
let your guard down his chest anything
can happen but you know Alina has gotten
much better at bullied she's gotten much
better at the three-minute portion and
she's gone faster and we've seen games
in which she just I mean even in highly
tactical positions she will find
resources in this you know snap of a
finger but John is still so experienced
I've played tons and tons of bullet with
him over the board online and I can just
say that he's his intuition is
first-rate he still is I think without a
doubt the favorite in those sections so
he's just trying to keep things level
now you wouldn't mind an advantage but I
think this is Elena's chance actually 5
minute or she okay
well I was just wondering because I
wasn't sure what the favor was I know
Alina has been absolutely incredible in
the bullet portion including her
mentions Eric Rosen which he mentioned
where she was tied go into bullet and
then it became one-sided in the one
minute portion but here 7 seconds up for
John you might as well play this one out
until it's clarified and I like it I
really think it's been a good strategy
both in terms of what you're saying
where John wants to get to bullet and in
terms of the Pacific we take c5 check
yeah 728 mmm-hmm check to his King and
then check here I'll pick up this room
and there we go well done by Lena good
solid technique didn't really give John
any chances and matches tight and we see
another Tory we do and you know John has
this good feeling because he won the
first game in aleena probably is like
well should I go for h6 g5
she doesn't put her pawn on d5 in this
game but it's also because John didn't
put his pawn on e4 mm-hmm he's blowing
this more like a London right and it's
instead of Bishop on f4 the bishops on
h4 but the bishop can always retreat to
g3 and then become full on London system
like mm-hmm and there's often these
ideas here well Elena's a fiancée
or I was gonna say I'm playing it should
takes f6 in and then D takes e5 and 94
but aleena trying eleena deciding to
remove the central attention White has
sly as a convenient player I've never
found these positions to be quite
appealing enough with cdcd because it
always seems like White has a very
slight pole but definitely not more than
that the good news for black is that
denies and c6 because any sort of will
reminds me of an exchange Slav right
where you you know CD CDs of both C
files are open there are plenty of lines
where the black knights already
committed to d7 but that's not where
your knight really belongs sometimes it
does if you put b6 Bishop d7 but the 96
clogs the C file for the time being and
then the question becomes what do you do
with there Bhishma c8 that's not an easy
question to answer I would think about
Bishop g4 even because my playing Bishop
g4 he's developing your bishop
connecting your rook and she plays
Bishop d7 yeah you know it's a little
passive I agree well I have the first
joke of the day for you Robert what did
the health conscious person say when
capturing on d4 I was following the CDC
recommendations
oh my gosh go away go on I'm tired of
you already know all right that's what I
wanted to grow up they even you know
watch this match like a fan I you're
getting booed I'm just look at the chat
you go man that tomatoes are getting
thrown some people liked it nobody liked
it not asesino permitted ladies and
gentlemen you liked it is vivid here cuz
it visits your maybe that it is here VIN
it come on you live it I bid it's got to
support me if everybody throws me to the
wolves at least I know vid it will be
there to defend my my honor no you don't
deserve your honor to be defended here
so we have a position where Y is going
to h3 and that means that the bishop can
come to g3 and we'll get trapped so
that's why aleena plays in that age 5
not allowing this Bishop back so g5
comes after this bishop but g5 you can
actually play so let's say
white make some random move like rook
see two intrepid g5 I sacrifice a piece
in G if I made a Knight takes pawn takes
Queen to h5 and unfortunate for you
there's too quickly a checkmate on h7
yeah and sometimes it's interesting but
when you when you have a bad experience
with a move um even if you are thinking
about playing that move in a completely
different position and you know that
move might have very little to do the
first time you played it you can have a
bad taste in your mouth and it's the
same thing if you play an opening you
got a good position but you played a bad
game you might be less inclined to play
that opening again so these
psychological factors I personally
believe play a pretty big role in the
making of decisions as the match goes on
I don't know what you think about that
but John going t5 you know there are
pros and cons that move I can't really
get a read on this position it's pretty
complicated you said you didn't know
what I thought about it and they didn't
even give me a chance to say what I
thought but I will agree with you
shocking I know that this D father was
very committal because now the pawn and
b2 is permanently under under threat
it's potentially weak and such as the
pawn there it's if you push your pawn at
some point I may still get Bishop to be
to come after your a3 pawn so it just
it's a committal decision because now
you can never close down the diagonal
yeah that's a great point shocking I
know
so savor that compliment
well nice city order I still can't get
over your CDC at CDC yeah I mean that
was so that was such genius that that
will all you know that will be all
you're you're gonna be thinking about
during many sleepless nights sleepless
for sure
and I'm scarred frankly scarred okay
that's a new one and it's not you know
like scars to your beautiful it really
scars me like the worst of ways like you
know Lion King scar mm-hmm well I don't
even know what to say Robert I'm I'm
glad you're speaking I'm totally not
sorry
well I think that from blacks point of
view here you know your pieces aren't
actually coordinating it very well and
h5 it's stopping the bishop from coming
to g3 and you would like to play g5 two
forces the g3 but your pawn on g6 is
necessary to remain there for the time
being
so John ridding himself of that b2 pond
was a little bit saddled with yep
because b5 would have kicked the night
away from c4 and actually gone after the
pawn and b2 but one question I'm having
is done is f5 a possibility here for
black just so I can protect the knight
of each 5 another time and then play g5
speaking of the psychological effects I
actually really liked that move and that
isn't a legitimate idea in some Kings in
Ian's position it's kind of a Dutch like
move but you get that clamp on the
center I thought if I was actually quite
strong alena going Knight of 6
but John can now before I think is is
pretty careful Bishop d7 and now John
might try to get a 5 in his position
there's a little bit flimsy that Queen
side there are some holes there I don't
think he has forever so maybe rook e1
and quickly try to push he 5 through not
sure what the correct way to play here
is but we seem to be matching on every
count rook e1 plate trying to go E 5
that makes sense especially with a queen
on Yi you want to open up this efile and
pressure the e7 pond with the Queen
behind it and your ideas there should be
5 or Bishop to a4 makes sense
Shion simply as Queen c8 I don't think
she's really threatening to sacrifice
the bishop on h3 but if you are John
keep an eye out on that because if that
move happens at a moment you know you're
not thinking about and it can collapse
your King set all together right exactly
and there we go he five from John hmmm
well Knight takes e5 he takes c6 I'm
just trying to figure out if Alina just
captures on on T 6 what's going on there
Knight takes g6 Queen c6 it's a bit of a
zoo in that position too many pieces in
the D file then Black Knight can come to
c3 the bug vision come to c3 I like
blacks position I do I was gonna say
that C 3 square therefore leave Knight
c3 immediately Wow
ok interesting so if I take on e7 with
my pawn I guess black will be better
because the Queen we're and
rook and minor but sometimes if you're
really worried about the position you do
something like that just to liquidate
and say I know it's a bit of a struggle
but it's not the end of the world
Bishop c6 played yeah aleena playing
again we noticed that in in some of her
matches how quickly she sometimes reacts
in tactical positions and her speed
accuracy sort of margins are absolutely
incredible
and John slipping down on the clock
again he's got to play a little bit
faster Queen g3 okay but Bishop e7 he
said this is when I think I drink Stern
but it's not CLE it's not entirely clear
I feel like Alina has some sort of
counter blow here I don't know where the
camera is going to come from but you
would need it like the rookie Hayes map
just by night 66 for the folio problem
so where's your counter play mmm there
should be five doesn't work
I was thinking briefly about rookie a96
rook takes he's seven but why does it
need to take the queen of course he just
takes the rook
yeah that's again that Queen on g3 is
such a stabilizing force it's gonna
guard that night on d6 and it's very
hard to get to it's it's protected by
that Bishop on g3 which limits the
Knights mobility interesting I I'm
trying really hard to come up with the
move so kind of Knight be fair I've just
to like protect d6 and give up the rook
down but then why is a four just kicking
the night away so
mmm-hmm it protects the pawn for one
move but a four kickstand night out yeah
I'm afraid there's nothing it's just
White's pieces are loose but they're all
defended by each other there might not
be pawns that defend White's pieces but
they're very well pledged to avoid any
sort of Forks or you know Intermezzo 's
just doesn't look good for Lina now
she's dipping to 30 seconds this is
because we liked her position and then
she went all active but she actually
helped John's Queen come to a better
Square and defy play that's a good move
if you take on f8 I just take back and
I'm down in exchange for one pawn and
I'm hoping that that in this pawn on d5
goes to D King takes
96 anybody yeah
96 Oh 95 John's is sinking his teeth
into those central squares but 96 looks
so tempting and then b5o I don't know
John is making some questionable
decision that in terms of war were
prioritizing the safety of his piece but
this is still completely winning just 96
even Yantic with the Queen guseong Man
Man Man Man Man Man Man Man Man Man Man
96 of 7 with Queen g6 Bishop c4 to
follow also was probably good but
there's no way John was in there was
little not that it mattered Queenie a
ribbon knight takes g6 JB JB with a
checkmate on the board yeah I mean his
white is too white games thus far it's
way too early to judge but that Tory
attack Alina's just not finding his end
of the position I feel like she's
switching between different plans it's
not that she's necessarily much worse
out of the opening
and here John don't play this is where
John played e6 and this time I feel like
he's simply confused the mobile order by
accident gave himself the h7 Square for
the bishop so any three g4e for the
bishop can just retreat all the way to
h7 clearing space for it just like which
I'm in the London system or what has the
pond h3 for the bishop on h4 to come
back these things here John throws h6
but now he's thinking again he's I don't
think he's very confident and he's
opening yeah it just feels like Elena's
still in problem and um yeah I don't
know too much about this line myself I
mean of course
judging from a superficial perspective
you know why does the centre and blacks
plan is gonna be to eventually play e5
that's assuming okay Lina goes 93 she's
basically claiming the Flex Knights are
kind of awkwardly placed especially that
night on b6
it's a good move 93 because it is
somebody has less space they want to
trade some pieces I'm gonna go back I'll
show the analysis port here because it
is a really instructive moment that
mostly was like what okay she's moved
her knight not a big deal but if she had
taken on d7 back when the knight was
there
so I went back there we go night 67 then
black can even capture back with the 97
and now these nights aren't stepping on
each other's toes you can play e5 as
Danya was pointing out
open up your darts for Bishop and you're
much happier to have this happen instead
in the game the Knights are now still on
d7 and d6 without a clear outpost for
them and then item d3 stops e5 stop c5
Orana Cincinnati
well Queen b3 but we're on assistant
heading somebody in the chat mentioned
John is in common version of Bill
Belichick so yeah II five is a good a
five is a good idea but you know we're
just gonna be thinking about what we're
doing that's there's things you can't
Johnny
Bill Belichick I might have been more
honest than any okay why doesn't a how
how does it even resemble Bill Belichick
in the slightest I feel like he's got
that like Bill Belichick never tilts
he's he's always disciplines not
disappointed to begin with but he's got
that zen-like approach to the game where
he's never unsettled he's very
experienced I can see I can actually can
see that comment have you ever seen Jon
wear a hoodie
um no that is a valid point but if he
coached in New England temperatures on
the sidelines I'm pretty sure he would
wear a hoodie as well
okay I've also never seen John and Bill
Belichick in the same room so you know
maybe he's Bill Belichick we're on a
Cincinnati so Elena's just again it
feels like John is not solved his
opening problems and here he's trying to
to get the engine started with be five
but that introduces a huge weakness on
c6 which Alina tries to exploit and here
you see the problem with these Knights
in the D file on the Queen there as well
you can't take on e5 because there's a D
takes e5 you have a problem with the
Queen on d8 you actually just lose your
night on d6
and otherwise the pawn to c6 under
attack at some point why can you be
certain on b5 because you've so many
pieces lined up attacking that square so
Queen c7 I guess in the move John she
play for them Brooke c1 yeah
queen ca yeah same idea
and not to pretend like this is winning
for white or anything of this sort
Elena's also got to be accurate I think
work see one's actually very interesting
vote because he cannot take on 85 there
there's gonna be Knight takes d5 or he
takes p5 at some point that's exactly
what olena does right b4 isn't if I
night to be fun it should have been fine
go from reading the channel here you
know this always appreciative of the
support in the chest community so shout
to you Ben and well before played so
here got might be fine now yeah 95 I was
thinking about taking on 85 and doing
Knight c4 instead but I don't know what
John intends a night p5 maybe Knight
takes e5 takes takes b5 and then goes c5
does that hold together I'm gonna put
that position in the blue that's dirty
I think I'm be far with my bishop though
right soon my pawn all right a knight
takes but so I found 95 and c5 look at
that Bishop on h7 White's just gonna go
Queen c4 and collect that bond I feel
like that's nastiness it doesn't feel
good you can heal supply crook c2 rook
c1 just yeah yeah that's font c5 and
blacks bishops are so passive in such a
variation whoa
hello 95 coming ha Alina is tactically
alert we see this every single master
brilliant move by Dave it looks good but
now it Knight be 5 because Bishop C ones
not a threat due to the fork
I was about to say that the bishop is
not actually threatening anything cuz
maybe 7 that's a critical square wasn't
just about attacking the piece Lina
look at the speed look at the confidence
incredible stuff here from her once
again and I see dad 6n saying John Slav
is really not getting the job done and I
mean the first gaming blunder so quickly
you can really blame the opening this
game it does feel like something about
the Slav is way more up Elena's Ally
than jobs yeah and I mean 95 maybe John
prepared for e3 and moves 6 which is
sort of the main main line these days
but surely he must have been aware of
that option and John choosing that lined
with Knight b6 which is not the main
line if they repeat this again we don't
have to go back there now but I can talk
about briefly with the mainline fairies
which is a lot sharper so something
just misfiring for John and he's we've
discussed this before this has happened
a lot of matches where one opening is
really suffering that's a very hard
problem to solve in match because you
don't necessarily have five different
lines lined up right and you have to
play just your next game right after the
previous one so if we get another slob
and say twelve minutes whenever the next
because John gets white next game and
after then I'll take and we know the
black pieces once more we'll see if he
repeats his exact ones what is happening
the Queenie's pings the knight on b5 to
the bishop on each oh I would probably
play rook to c2 yeah is it the rook of B
is also hanging no how am I gonna see
you how about take it take that rook and
then Doris yeah
Oh c7 yeah it's so much hanging that
yeah rook c7 Roxy - there we go
oh my gosh shut it - Alina sorry to cut
you off that died no no she is rebounded
extremely well she's lost the first game
she wins
with white and said game she lost the
third game and she's rebounded he
rebounding again and John the same right
he lost Game two and then he was able to
rebound in Game three so they're trading
punches right now yeah they're not like
two boxers
you know circling around the ring
they're two boxers who are or throwing
uppercuts and sideways blows so you know
just fascinating to watch and yeah both
both of these players just showing their
superiority with the white pieces and
both of them are problems to solve so
I'm fascinated to see who is going to
solve their problem of the black pieces
first I think that Lina needs to change
something up too because we're focusing
on John with the black he's in the slob
because he's black in this game but yeah
she has not been convincing when she's
played these lines where John plays a
story attack and just kind of play
simple chess but every single time that
we've seen it this far it feels like his
opponent's struggle whether it was Greg
or Lina they just don't have the right
footing to withstand the pressure that
the Tori offers yeah the nature of their
problems is different also because John
seems to have a theoretical problem I
feel like he's not sharp on the theory
in this line and he's worth straight out
of the opening Alena sometimes she even
comes close to equalizing her problem
seems to be one of comfort and you know
the positions that she gets it matches
John style and she doesn't seem to rid
herself fully of the pressure so both of
them with equivalently significant
problems but they're different in nature
I like the way you you framed that
because they are very different for sure
one of them is like should I stop
playing this opening all together the
other is how do I actually improve my
opening because my after eight moves and
totally fine and then four moves 8
through 16 that's where I'm getting in
trouble verses I don't feel comfortable
move six which just seems to be John's
well exactly and here Alena putting the
finishing touches on really a
masterpiece thus far not such not to
attempt to jinx her but she's up an
exchange and John completely just no
counter play I mean his position is so
passive there's not no intrigue Alina
can basically do anything she wants
within reasonable balance Queen c4 rook
t1 yep they're going to push or to take
on e6 depending on how black responds
your black also it's 12 seconds John
busy five I would probably play d6 but
then he's looking at the east six square
is that all one big deal a 96 white
resigns I don't think it's a big deal
but Elena's probably saying hey wait a
second I don't want to give John a sort
of activity she was Queen see for me
she's just rook c8 yeah and then Bishop
c5 streaming in that night is mine total
absolute domination look at this
position dissing there we go
this was a great game from start to
finish man just one of those and we've
seen Robert so many masterpieces another
one of my favorite moments by the way
when Anna's sitarski play those
positional masterpieces she lost the
match of course I think - Greg correct -
Greg yes but in the five minute portion
we have seen games worthy of classical
games if I didn't see the time control
and some of them I can easily predict
that this was you know game it some
tournament well maybe if there were
tournaments but ya know she they match I
was intoxicated some excellent a chest
there she unfortunately did not make it
through a get ready but she did play
some great games and here we see a diff
and opening from John John led the way
in this we didn't put the Torian said
we're into a verb goes in and now the
Queen on g6 so this is actually really
annoying for white because the pawn on
g2 is a target and that is what I was
going to say it but John plays the
theory but I could hate with Queen to c2
is played so if we just go back in time
I'm gonna show them analysis board where
this move Queen g6 just kept white stuck
for the time being as the g2 pawn needs
the defense of the bishop
so that is why Queen c2 and the exchange
happens very quickly because if Queen
can no longer stay for black on the King
side over here there's no good square to
work with and betrayed and rook da Dhin
what do you make of these queenless
middle games Danya i white is just
better and it's annoying but then yeah
totally fine for black yeah exactly and
then you see games at the high level and
I used to play Barry Buzan and I
actually had this I have the position
after queen g6 a few times and I don't
remember having this exact endgame but
it always feels like you know the
computer sometimes evaluates it as zero
zero zero zero but just there's
something about it that seems slightly
better for white before white seems to
have that free pressure on the Queen
sign of black it's kind of reactive in
this position black doesn't really have
a plan of her own it just and again it
seems to favor John these types of
positions so once again I'm not totally
sold on Elena's you know the thrust of
our opening choice but it seems like
she's on the Pats it just equalized and
completely trading the bishops that
Knights not gonna get to c5 without
being captured I don't know we'll see
and what is know about this Lauren but
the thing is for Alina you get the two
bishops and that said the bishops
advantage but the run at fate is
totally useless in a position like this
look at White's pawn change from f2 to
d4 it means that the bishop doesn't have
anything were to scope out nicely five
plate and I mean it could have taken on
a c5 first and I honestly I think I
would have preferred to take on c5 first
just cuz I don't like the bishop on f8
but what do you think in her
decision-making process there Danielle
like why didn't she capture on c5 why
don't you leave the night there
you know Mark Devore at ski of course
the famous coach actually talks about a
concept he calls I think in English a
superfluous night when you have two
nights that both want to live on the
same square and I'm not saying they both
want to be on c5 but that is kind of
what I'm saying so Elena might Bank on
her bishop in the long run you might
look at this and say well look at that
Bishop terrible but she might at some
later point think well maybe that Bishop
ends up on d6 and maybe the position
eventually opens up so I think she
doesn't want to commit I'm not sure
that's the right decision but I think it
does make a certain degree of sense well
you call it superfluous and that well
you're not calling it but you're
reiterating the point but superfluous
night but what about this superfluous
minor piece on d6 square like you just
said what about you well what about the
superfluous commentator name Robert has
okay well I don't think that's gonna go
over very well with the chat so you
better watch yourself mister but I mean
it it is true though right the bishop
and a knight want to share the d6 square
that's true that's a good point yeah and
that Knight is tied down to the pawn um
b7 so I agree I think the immediate
passivity of the bishop kind of
outweighs any long-term considerations
maybe John can go ahead and play p4 at
some point well you start with g4 what
do you make of that because I actually I
mean I understand why he's trying to
expand on the kingside but at some
moment I'm worried black is gonna play
h5 and be first to the action there's a
Bishop e7 unless you play h5 r okay Jade
things like that but black just doesn't
really you know she doesn't have the
true activity here she can never play b6
because then c6 becomes a problem so
what if she goes for h5 now right to
open up I don't know trying to get some
hair for her pieces John would never
have played the move but I think he
could've captured on h5 yeah and then
maybe put on I don't have four well it's
funny because when I would play these
end games and I lost a lot of them
actually to some GM's
I would always check with the computer
and it would always be Igor even 0.14
quack and I could never understand why
that is because it just shows you how
important it is to proc to
evaluate the position not just stare at
the computer evaluation but we'll see
how what Lina handles this maybe she'll
hold her own I mean John is not exactly
I don't know that rook h1 though Robert
so you didn't like the rook trait just
because blacks works we're doing all of
nothing
well I'm a little bit worried that yeah
that's exactly what I'm saying that if
you put the rook on b1 and just went
before I didn't really see a downside to
that maybe black would play a six and
John didn't see a follow up but and Bill
full any of life in this position before
is one of those super committal moves
because you give black to see Foursquare
permantly so for as long as your pawn
the b2 you can play b3 and kick out the
night yeah and John taking a very
thinking pose you know those hands
spread out the fingers spread out g5
vitalina also pretty committal is that
justified is she thinking as someone's
away f5 and going I kind of attacked
this white King I suppose but again
there's that problem of the beep on f5
GF and you really don't wanna play b6
that just seems absurd weakening the c6
pawn like that so can I start with k e8
inkwell and what about kingi you did
Knight d3 night about Knight g3 good g3
I wanted to play b6 and King D 7 but
maybe I'm not not quite as good as I
thought but I don't know I'm getting my
King to protect that pawn some pretty
good I mean let me let me throw you a
token compliment to as a token of
apology let's say I already forgave you
so you know you're all good okay thank
you thank you fingers pressing I might
get emotional here but let me come to
the game while before Jia oh if f3 now
Knight c4 okay it's the e3 square what a
move rook h4 Elina with a tree and look
at the time situation almost two minutes
extra for Elina it might seem like a
peaceful end game but that matters it's
there's stuff going on here you say
peaceful I say full of pieces because
there's a lot of life left or night c4
maybe then Bishop takes c5 to follow
because next before doesn't Titus eat
three pawn and how do you protect III
King F - there's always rookie too -
what about rook c3 rooks III I'll
probably take you on c5 right
and then I didn't have a follow-up I
just was gone with it well I guess we'll
see because well Bishop c5 DC Knight B -
first of all there's rugby 3 and white
stroke guy that's a terrible terrible
line for black is that night uh need to
you don't want to sleep on it if it ever
lands on half five that spells some
trouble for for black so aleena with a
very important decision here I think
this is the critical moment she played
b6 and did it in 19 seconds and she's a
huge lead on the clock John under a
minute and honestly my look at this
position it's still very good but 9390
probably takes techniques and the knight
g3 or DCI see what he's doing wow I'm
impressed I'm so I'm just impressed with
the speed of decision making and it's
not like these players are making
mistakes at every move these decisions
are actually quite deep I'm kind of
wondering 985 looks ridiculous but 95
Elizabeth pressure on b3 makes the
United c5 have to leave what are the
moves in 93 doesn't look right I agree I
don't know I feel like like of something
here right it does have the look of a
position where there's has to be
something a timely Bishop d6 will be
annoying the running brook each - yep
what about no that's too crazy I thought
even Bishop d6 immediately but Knight b2
is something that I came to my mind's
eye 91 potentially but I didn't see a
follow up after night a6 no I like that
nice things Bishop d6 here to take on c6
they're just getting me in time a 91
there's routine Rangers back and forth
yeah okay but what about Knight b-29 a
610 Bishop t6 then 66 yeah I was looking
for some sort of hacky okay but that
rotates shoe and King e7 I thinking of
doing something positional just
basically claiming all will see oh
you're a devious man I'm nicer maybe
Elena's under the same illusion that I
am she's been a minute and a half on
that move which is great time agent
she's still up she what happened I came
up with an idea
91 rook t3 rook h1 sorry it's all that's
filthy mean I just want to be positional
that nights gonna be trapped on p7 oh
that's so filthy and she plays c5 also
pretty good isn't it or is it oh no I
don't think it is cuz then DC be seen I
see five nights you wonders rule t3
right and then she's gonna take on e3
but now she I mean she's probably find
they're actually okay yeah I mean 93 but
no it's definitely on top there 93 95
John must be breathing a sigh of relief
here he's definitely happier here than
he was a second ago but bed rook h1
maneuver dunya poof I mean I kept trying
to make it work and I was just looking
for the right square to force white
truck onto you made fetch happen so you
know Gretchen we news to be proud of you
oh my gosh you haven't seen Mean Girls I
mean I I know some me and goes I haven't
seen okay we need a pole I'm tired of
this need a pole because Danya you gotta
go man you gotta go all right everybody
I think I'm gonna take a nice walk it's
beautiful day ya know Carol animals I
think the pole should be how many for
Danya and I think the answer is none for
you Glenn Cocco is that another
reference oh my gosh just get out of
here all right I've done you know when
it rains it pours when you mean one
mistake as the saying just follows the
other follows the other this is this is
unaccepting oh well bet your chest jon
is seven point seven seconds so I think
it is down upon the 25 being a
great piece but then nd5 also pretty
pretty darn good here and I would even
consider f5 at some point for black to
play for a win okay Jon Jon's definitely
thinking about playing for a win but I
don't see any way to make progress here
he okay see one I'm gonna maybe but he's
gotta make a move he's got four seconds
okay you repeated she could have played
for more consider
yeah rook up two and then I fight
because that pawn in a six was doing an
excellent job she was maybe worried
about some beef I break that was like I
understand well there was a knight right
in your grill I'll bring a buddy now
mock ass I'm gonna bring thee now
support and keep talking about that game
done yeah no I mean not much to say
anything I think objectively it was
equal so the first draw in the match
it's been pretty bloodthirsty thus far
yeah I saw then gave him up I'm a bit
curious about it the night seems good
but the problem is not an outpost so you
would like a pawn protecting so the rook
is kind of tied down d5 is under blacks
control but it did feel like a Billy Joe
wanted to play for more that's why
everyone is keen do you want ultimately
if the key was smart though to agree on
the draw so now we have this position
where it's a Bonomi but it's a very
closed position this is you know but
yeah there should be thing technically
computer always likes these positions
for white because of the space advantage
but I haven't haven't seen John play
much Kings Indian structures I'm excited
to see how it's gonna handle this this
cuz you just want to convert him to
become a king Xena player it's not gonna
happen
Danya it's not happening oh you know
some people don't give the Kings Indian
a chance
I actually one of my idols was Tigran
Petrosian but then I found out
apparently he said before a game he
asked what what is my opponent play and
the response of the Kings Indian and you
know the response is something like well
I won't disturb him from playing that so
anybody who talks smack about the Kings
Indian don't do that are on me because
John wouldn't play the Kings in you
because whose pawn it's on the d5 square
it's White's right that's and that is a
good point that's valid but I'm not sure
I'm not sold on what Elena's doing she's
giving up that e5 square that's a
monster monster outpost for black and
what Lina wants is F takes d4 Knight
takes e4 it's a moment but the enemy v
is so strong here you're right the
bishop is tied to the poncey force you
can't play Bishop c2 without dropping
upon h1
very very zen-like by Elena she's not
worried about that night but Bishop d7
here for black and then black could add
at b5 into the mix at some point no John
is definitely solved more than salsas
opening problems being problems are now
on whites on white side now black is for
sure better here and many five is just
going to remain there there's actually
no easy way for white to pilot pressure
the one thing you have to be a bit care
about is sometimes there's some exchange
sacrifices right yeah fee Matic exchange
sack on the e5 square to plug in my
Dhoni for afterwards but it takes some
time your e takes at 594 and all the
stuff it's it's not quick enough I
missed another chance for an obscure pun
i sending opening problems are on are on
white side but i was going to say the
opening problems aren't Hassan Whiteside
[Music]
7% of the chatters Man Man Man Hassan
Whiteside whose defense is overrated
that Hassan Whiteside yeah but he
started to shoot threes
I respect for any Center who shoots who
shoots threes well sure of course but
how about chasing blocks when maybe you
shouldn't do that okay whatever let's
let's go back to the chest because
you're assigned Whiteside comma you need
to save me from from bad puns and the
way to do that is to strictly analyze
the game I don't think I'm gonna make
any comments that are not directly
related to the game Anna for everyone to
death at least that way I won't make any
bad puns so I have someone have a PhD in
dunya jokes that's a great anyone has a
PhD which which was conferred on you
without your asking it's you Robert
believe me in honorary degrees what
you're saying yeah Paige the emeritus
from university of narrative scheme can
I have a virtual graduation you know
ceremony so I can you can really be yen
I mean I'll be following the footsteps
of every University now just conferring
a diploma
Danya you I'm here for it but Queen b6 I
mean look at this be for square the
Queen just trying to come to the c4 pawn
is weak Knight takes c3 now is a threat
with a b2 pawn
under attack everything seems in some
ways to be going right before black but
I am a little worried about the kingside
it's a okie three rook lifts over to g3
is that in the cards it is and we've
talked about this before how when you
have one good square it's easy to assume
oh I'm completely safe for the rest of
the game but you also made a very good
point I think about a potential exchange
sacrifice if Bishop 65 maybe black will
even capture with upon I think that is
premature but at some point later
combined with the rook lifts I'm not
sure about Queen b6 maybe that's a
little bit overly I don't know in
cautious but John also trying to get a
sweet tip knee for us so I understand
what he's trying to do when you progress
a 4 and C 4 you have the b4 and the b3
squared to drop your queen into
attacking the c4 pawn so I definitely
get it but there is something that feels
a bit airy on the black king side
because if image of h6 immediately
should be considered even your bishop of
d3 is hanging Oh your bookie says a
matter o 7 and we're gonna show that
we're gonna show that so pull the
analysis board Bishop h6 if you trying
to chop on each six in chopping d3
rookie 7 comes and that is a meeting
threat here that is disastrous for black
I think that's all that what Elena's
thinking about but the problem isn't the
blacks gonna take the bishop I feel like
the problem might be black might ignore
whether okay e8 and the question then is
is it worth spending that money Tempe
trading the bishop I feel like the
answer might be yes but I'm not sure
these reach six make sense you just
undermine a defense of the black King
and now John is actually a little bit
ahead of the clock that really finally
played and it's just a more difficult
position of play from black side because
of King safety and they do take on each
sixth do you bring your knight back to
g6 immediately is your at five pond
going to quickly fall and if that's the
case are you in huge trouble when that
happens do you play Ruby d8 now or after
taking on a g6
there are many questions and I don't
really have the interest I would not
take on h6 I don't like dragging be
Queen into the game okay
and as soon as I say that of course the
capture happens
well now I know I completely agree with
you Robert I mean first of all white
could even consider I was thinking about
sacking any fat but there isn't quite
enough firepower because the rook lift
comes too late black can always go King
h8 now there is Queen takes T 6 with the
idea of Knight takes c3 Queen g3 chap
and then picking off the bishop or
picking up the knight and defending
White's own night
I feel like Queen d6 might be strong
with on Queen takes c3 right root
deprived 23 Warcraft 3 its prey gets
crazy the Queen d1 check and at the very
least black is temporarily up a piece
but the king is never gonna find true
shelter on g8 so that is a crazy line I
was just thinking about a simple rookie
streets of Brooklyn aha and after Queen
takes c3 I wanted to make but she takes
a 5 happen because my Queen protects my
rook the rug wattle Queen rook g3 checks
Queen takes h7 mating ideas all this
stuff is available that's a very nice
move and berlina she doesn't not forever
to make a decision sometimes even if you
make the right decision but you have 10
seconds left it it's not good enough you
need to do it fast I think she's
deciding between rookie 3 and Queen 66
that would be my guess I don't see any
other super appealing candidate moves I
thought about rook f3 but it doesn't
seem to work after a knight takes and
then rookie 7 kappa7 seems a little bit
too much I love that you're getting into
my sort of wavelength here of
sacrificing other people's pieces
because really exactly move that you
likely wouldn't really consider in your
own game because of all the other
tempting options yeah not my pieces go
for it some kind of Bishop takes effort
nah doesn't work I'm trying I thought I
was thinking about that too I feel like
we're they're starting to reach the same
way blink to use your term Robert oh no
no rookie three played that was what my
first instinct was trying to bring this
hook over you know what worries me
though but Queen takes c3 Bishop f5 rook
up 5 and the rookin f1 is hanging with
check yes oh yes yeah yes Jenna yes well
I'm not quite sure which Alina cat
Gosselaar Fabio Annika shoots there
as in mind here queen c3 is there
anything else I mean you understand what
the problem because okay you could still
just do that and then take on c3 and
claim the bet d6 pawn is incredibly weak
and basically indefensible but there's a
negative seven at a time let rook g3
you're gonna just make me before I can
do it so we're saying group take step 5
rook takes c3 rook takes f1 check King a
CO 2 h2 and who like me to find a move
of some sort and this is what's
happening right now
just defends maybe rook a fake Queen d6
Roccat 5 take the head but that is that
is uh okay I'm gonna use that term for
the last time that is very mom pass
position for black maybe 96 96 that
makes sense cutting off the Queen from
the d6 4 but then there's rook g3 or h4
h5 some kind of combination of those
ideas
ya know it just seems practically
speaking I'm sure there is some defense
but it looks so nasty rook e8 coming to
protect okay but then rookie 3 1948 but
Hg
I'm not saying I love it but I agree
that's at least something okay but
Elena's just grabbing the pawns that
does make some sense this is gonna be a
time scramble buckle in ladies and
gentlemen I'm buckling up I'm getting my
seat belt fastened and d6 played that
gives me Queen d5 checking push my
honesty I've grouped you in one by job
and our key three and my queen guards
the night there's no discovery what to
do for John John is a trouble mate
somewhere but there's no we're good to
go mate c6 maybe maybe 97 or 96 I'm not
sure which mean yeah but that oh and job
London well he does a blood race oh
that's interesting actually tries to
build a fortress but I don't believe it
I don't believe it either but there's no
way to break through in the King's like
King g3 kh4 king g5 can you shake I'm
not even kidding
yeah breno king in you've got all the
world I didn't like about that with c6
see six wins Oh Elena missing some
chances here now she brings her king
she's got to be careful there's a lot of
forks here pins
especially when the king is this close
to the Queen
Oh Queen h6 crude okay whatever 55 check
now we need shape though okay my keys
Hanuman don't get checked whoa
repeats oh you had to go fish before now
now move it John's gotta lose a king
it's a king be 6 and then Bishop e4
right I guess for John with no time on
the clock c6 c c6 look at Elena finding
it instantly yep she's gonna fight and
you stop the pawn and strategy tried
upon and just call it a 5 a 6 and it's
over
Queen f6 was good here but okay this is
just good enough eight seven and okay
aleena mopping up here what a move a7
couldn't take because of Queen B a check
wait but don't see can be 700 K there's
some chances here I don't think you
actually are entire I can g8
if you can put that rook on g6 sometimes
you can make a job but here the Queen
will be able to take especially with two
G pawns yeah but still I mean no Alina
needs to be a little careful not to
looking if I would play King f8 36 Queen
it okay create six and g6 is you know
there's some that was funny about that I
think let's play with some fire here
that was amusing
please take my queen is the bouquet come
on rookie Queen Queen e6 Queenie 525 is
nice oh my gosh evil we're gonna blow my
mouse for hitting me that was ridiculous
and what so well calculated there's no
stalemate because of that pun so if you
take you to push your pawn in g6 g7 and
you clean it and win the game but I want
to point out that it's funny because I
was thinking of a little ladder yo Queen
e6 check Queen e5 check Queen d5 check
and the picking of the rook on e that
was good job she's out Queen f7 Queen f8
so quickly to liquidate into a win so
let's go to the live game we see that
Alina's pawn is on b4 so this is like
chronic style right d4 Knight of 6 mm m3
d5 and then playing for beef I didn't
crumb makes you see this is black a lot
yeah this is actually a pretty
line it's it's hard for white to handle
this position because that pot on before
is lodged in what's throat and by the
way this probably will be the last game
of the five-minute segment was a very
very important game for John a loss
would be not disastrous but incredibly
unpleasant because the momentum right
now especially after a win of that
quality and with those types of tactics
is firmly on Elena's side so we'll see
how John handles this c3 okay trying to
liquidate the queenside
yeah just being solid made a wrong error
just trying to protect everything one by
one the pawns here and 97 played by
Alina so the bishop becoming a six very
likely to put pressure on the e2 pawn
but I'm always annoyed in position as
this Danya that I want to play rook b8
and I sometimes forget that there's a
bishop when I for stop me from doing so
that sounds like a you problem but no I
actually agree that Bishop especially in
combination now a5 I think is an
important move and this is what I'm
talking about though when you sort of
get this exchange Slav with an item d7
and if I played good move and Bishop h6
also a good move but you know sometimes
you regret having this night on d7 here
it's probably fine but there's so many
variations that I've seen where you just
after night goes e7 then you finally
take on d5 right that's a good point
and they're kind of playing this
cat-and-mouse maneuvering game they're
trying to okay Knight d2 of course
trying to get rid of that Knight 94 and
I would even yeah I'm not sure why it
has anything I'm considered going back
to f3 and back to e5 95 definitely
better script f3 plane that is she I
don't know about that I feel like John's
position gets a little flimsy here
bishop see what a good move oh and b3 if
Knight c1 maybe I would I would love to
play b3 no nice e5 I'm trying to make
'if I've happened of course doesn't work
as a bishop covering the square yeah but
still since olena's got an important
decision here I would even still
consider b3 in this position I was
trying to draw the arrow instead of
dragging I clicked so went the eroom
from before to a3 but but now an IP
seven by the way sorry to interrupt you
97 96 might be very strong such an easy
thing to overlook 97 hitting the Queen
and then drying it the d6 square that's
gonna find it is he I believe he is if
he's already thinking for this long I
think he's at least open to an unusual
possibility in there it is there it is
and Quincey at 96 coming in Queen I'll
just take Weasley probably the best
defense and it's very fortunate for
black the pawns on f3 because this for
an F - oh God yeah that would be a big
problem but now for Knight see for you
to play D takes e4 if you feel good and
that actually might not be bad at all
for but you know it's funny because you
you find a tactic and you think you're
so cool then you look at the position
this happens very often and you're like
wait a second am I even better maybe
that was good for my opponent but no I
think I do think the position is now
unbalanced at least John will have some
chances so capturing on c4 e for plate
now what is this beautiful center with D
44 points black only has one pawn the
center but this is kind of standard
Queens pawn game compensation for black
and says that you hand your opponent the
central squares and pawns in the center
but then you have these Queen side
pastures b4 and c4 so I mean Don yet
when you position like this when do you
consider playing a move like c3 I know
it it advances your past pawn but also
creates an isolated pawn so when you
thinking about that move yeah that's a
great point I mean it's a very tempting
move but right now I would say it's bad
because it saddles you with that I mean
white will very safely block date it I
would first try to make a move along the
lines of Brooke II to see okay so a
little play that I mean I personally I
think it's a little bit too much of a
risk but I can also understand why she
would play it I mean John has to
distract himself from that t4 pawn which
could also become a weakness so I'm not
gonna say this is a mistake I think it's
you know it's not unnecessarily
something I would do but it has its
purse it is a position though if you
could play a seven to a five and then
push the white pawn back to a four black
would be so happy to put
before and protect everything the issue
is once the butcher gets it before now
it's not as grounded right it's not just
protected by a pawn so that if I move
them earlier and you can see it paying
dividends even now thanks to black not
being able to play it and then move
herself Ruby it is strong it broke FC
one there's rugby - and you can't
capture on B 2 because that rook on a1
will hang so I'm not sure who the trader
Brooks actually favors Micah Clark what
if I take into a situ I was wearing the
same thing so rupee one rupee 1 c2
he probably played a rook c1 and rook c8
and you're part of protection with
bishop f1 Queen c3i you just bring the
Queen in too quickly real I see what
you're getting at
don't worry you know though h6 says
she's not I guess she's not Jews didn't
have to operate with a big sense of
urgency because upon him before you
enter an arbor a great point about the
bishop on before but it's not like
blacks necessarily in danger of losing
that bond right out right and E 5 puts a
finally e5 happens and she's just trying
to open up the dark square so if d5 and
eventual Bishop c5 is what she's relying
on but also took Queen c7 protecting a
seventh running Bishop c5 I like blacks
position yeah I stand corrected I mean
at first I thought it was too big of a
commitment but from a practical
perspective I like like what Elena's
done now I have to read this comment by
Jason sunshine we had has anybody asked
Elina to stop being so strong other
people would like to have a chance to
win that was funny yeah I mean I am just
impressed the speed always impresses me
because you know when you give most
people 45 minutes yes they can find a
good move but when you have a blitz game
with such love at a time and you see
someone time and time again making the
best move and finding enterprising toxic
insinuations that always impressed so
now John the ball is in his court he
needs to make something happen here this
is it's not clear whether it's going to
be the last game in the
segments it depends how much these
players think because we just over 2
minutes remaining and John is thinking
because Queen takes be one there's
Queens e85 for instance and rook takes
be one is Bishop c5 but Bishop c5
doesn't exist with the Queen um b1 and
the Brooklyn C one because rook 63 would
have happened but now the rook has been
distracted here's Bishop c5 and Danya I
may at the very least when I see a
position like this I think if I lose my
c3 pawn I still such good control over
the dark squares that my knight will try
to outclass your bishop but in an
endgame
f 3 e 4 D 5 look at those that connect
upon chain that will be a problem for
black I agree but even if tragedy
strikes and all the pieces are traded
off the board except the bishop in the
night and what white loses or black was
the c3 pawn you can plant a knight on d6
so it's never going to be easy to win
for white oh and John dropping that pawn
an endgame now I feel like with the
blockading knight on d6 could only be in
blacks favor also good job you look at
that time situation look at me
oh nice fine Bishop Miege three small
little over second Oh John need to play
that a sigh of relief by Alina I'm sure
bish a tree actually den black has to
trade on d7 and lose a c3 pawn and
there's no more advantage yeah and by
the way someone in the chat asking can
one of the commentators pronounce
Elena's last name it specially in ska is
the proper pronunciation Kesha nice guy
I always say cash and sky with Kochanski
yeah but it basically you know most
Russian names sound long but you
pronounce them how it's spelled and
she's trying to be money in this game
she's at one point John is 14 seconds
left and that weighs three I mean
that is just a big missed opportunity
for John you think he realizes he missed
that I think he's I didn't seen a
mouthing man man man and Elena will not
give him 2 chances rook c5 very precise
from I think cuz now that I comes to b6
this is looking nasty for John he
realizes a Robert if he saw it on this
move I think he realizes it if the rook
on c2 is not any better I guess that's a
sad oversight for Jane
sorry continue no I'm good
this deep aunt can be used as a decoy as
well so you go d6 d7 exactly 9066 it's
not rook on c5 you get the Queen on a
one is slightly type down to that rook
hmm
and is there some kind of Queen eight
for here but then just rip c1 back yeah
I would consider d6 Queen a1 check and
now Queen a1 Queen D one Queen a1
there's Rick c1 oh yeah this is actually
surprisingly annoying it is I mean
there's rook c6 c7 or t6 but and there
we go Robert your move for Queen d3
wasn't an ice queen d43 it should have
one only move Oh black well that was so
nice because d7 you sack the knight and
the pod pushes that's why John Bishop f1
but here look at look at Alina goat
taking away e5 is a possibility King be
87 yeah should just win yep you don't
want to go rip c6 because of Eve five
but Alina patiently bringing a five
peanuts white down completely
yes this might see it I guess also yeah
did the trick
just collect all the pawns okay good job
but c2p2 thanks we're on the same exact
yeah wait wait a second is Alina got a
trait that I later just needs to find
see to it because she assumes that it's
not a move and there we go
and it's one check be working out the
way the best that John has his
sacrificing the bishop for c2 the time
is up in the five-minute portion by the
way yep so Alina will be up two points
and in the grand scheme of things given
how evenly matched these players are
that is a lot what a performance by
Alina and the five and a portion and for
John I think part of this is that his
clock management has yet been getting
into trouble in this game he missed
Bishop h3 he put it one move too late
but if he will go over it after this
game concludes but had he found that
racially to move earlier he would
have survived this game very likely and
now he's just playing just to he should
play because the time patrols over so as
soon as game is done they get a break
but he may have a chance with his past
eponymous yeah whenever you have a
passed pawn you don't want to resign the
problem is
you can exactly go rookie four so holy
that contains the pawn now King c7 and
John can resign and John will resign I
believe right now and there we have it
so I'm gonna go back just a little
briefly to that moment so we can show
everybody a missed opportunity and it's
an instructive point we don't want to
harp on players blend or anything but
rook c2 was a move that just says
unblock hating your past pond you're not
pushing it but Bishop
h3 right away hit this man on d7 then I
only said we can't move because behind
the knight is this work on c8 and if you
play move to defend the night either
Queen c7 or up c7 I take your knight you
have to take and you lose your defense
of this pollen c3 we restore material
equality and that makes sure that the
worst is behind white and it's a missed
chance for John and well he says plenty
of time left in this match we're gonna
go on a break but when we return it'll
be the three plus one time patrol of
this I am no GM speech a championship
match brought to you by chess calm
[Music]
and as we return we sir mind the players
I've left you another player's pleasure
I know how they stack up against each
other and who they beat mine all of you
on the audience that John has been
completely dominant throughout his
journey seats I'm no James fetus
champion final he 122 650 math to seven
at 5:15 and six have no close matches
but Daniel you look at Alina do you
think that because she's had a close
match in the opening one and even the
second match it was a 5-point win at the
end but it was tied going to bullet does
that actually favor her in what is going
to be surely a close match today yeah I
actually think it might because you know
the more she's winning these matches and
she's winning them by wider and wider
margin you know even Alina pointed out
she's gaining confidence and she can
just see herself improving and when you
see yourself playing better and better
and winning by wider and wider margins
her opponents being you know equally r
stronger than they than the last
opponent that confidence really really
helps we've talked time and time again
about the psychological undercurrent of
these matches so you know John's got
some serious work to do here
yeah let's remind everybody about the
overall bracket because there were 16
fabulous players we're down to the final
two but you know we saw chess explained
take on Alina in the opening round we
saw Elizabeth Bates taking on air of
Rosen and there weren't so many upsets
if you will
I guess Erik beating Alina on in terms
of seeding was kind of an upset but Erik
being the much more experienced as an
online list flare it wasn't too big of a
surprise I'd say but throughout this
week John and Alina have just from the
very beginning of this I feel like they
were the two people that everybody was
keeping their eyes on and looking out
for right yeah I mean they we could
immediately tell and Alina played that
very very close match against Christoph
who by the way played his heart out as
well but you know they are both
incredibly strong classical players and
incredibly strong woods players so it's
not that it's a surprise
but you know we don't want to minimize
how inch
some of those other mattress were they
might not have been upsets in the end
but we've been treated to so many
incredible incredible moments for sure
we have and speaking of you know we want
you to get involved getting both with
hashtag speech s because I've daily
question is what has been your favorite
moment for me I am GM speech s
championship we look forward to reading
some of your answers out loud we
mentioned some of our favorites
including Eric Rosen's swindle and
getting a stalemate from McDonald Queen
and then also the match between Teddy
Coleman and Danni reg is what you picked
is just the one I went to the tiebreaker
of course is fantastic but without
further ado games about to start so
maybe the fair moment from the I'm
non-gm speeches championship is about to
happen to come well so far it's been an
incredibly high level five minutes
section they are off and normally in the
situation I'd be talking about the
importance of keeping one's composure
but when John is playing I don't have to
talk about keeping he should be talking
to me about keeping one's composure he
is the ultimate expert at that
but you mentioned time management and
the opening both of those are gonna be
the X factors and another sloth do you
think he looked that up in the break
Robert yes I think he must have because
mm-hmm you don't keep going into an
opening that has been giving him
troubles thus far and you want to check
it before you keep on doing otherwise
you switch your opening entirely so the
business on h7 we've seen this position
before this beautiful pawn chain for
white from G to G for they're moving so
quickly that my highlights are getting a
race but you see the point there's a
pawn chain here there's a bad bishop on
h7 and so the bishop was dominated by
the pawn chain 93-94 we've seen this
exact position yeah and we concluded
that and there we go a5 okay so clearly
John playing were concretely now
optically I still feel like White's got
the edge
but I suppose e5 helps black solve the
opening problems earlier is he kind of
procrastinated with that move and then
he never got a chance to play it 92 Oh
92 I think I mean it's not the end of
the story Queen takes b7 but that looks
pretty nasty for white I don't think it
was an intentional exchange sacrifice so
much
and oversight that you played by John
yeah and see that good thing about when
you look up a line and your opponent
plays the move that looks really good
you know in your head that there has to
be some sort of a reputation so it's
easier to find it's almost like someone
taps you on the shoulder that's why you
know it's easier to solve problems
because you know there's a tactic okay
so where the knight is trapped and what
Alena wants is to you know plain nh-2
please do that so when I take it off
your back I have these you have pawns in
the center that at least give me some
compensation but of course John is much
better but I liked your point there
Tania that when you look up a line and
it'll tell you Oh white is slightly
better but Queen b3 wasn't the
recommended move but then you pump this
Queen Batarian wait why was that not
recommended then what exactly and then
you have 92 okay so John prioritizing
the pawn on e5 I still like Matt h2
because that would have also kind of you
know disrupt to the safety of whites
game with Queen B is an interesting mode
if f4 I would imagine that he would play
Knight takes h2 I think so
so when I would play up for if I early
and I don't see an alternative you don't
want to give the e5 pawn because you
played Bishop takes f1 and a Knight
takes e5 there's Bishop g3 even as
Bishop d6 so like if something exchange
cleanly so even though black is gonna be
better no matter what alena does she
just once it makes his convoluted puzzle
she does play out for I do not like her
time management though she's in three
two seconds to play at four yeah but
that's a movie basically I mean you
should determine that there's no pin as
you pointed out but once you do you need
to play this quickly that's one of the
chances aleena can have in this position
as if she can make John think and start
doubting himself and get into time
pressure because John or no John as
composed as he is without it with how to
die there must be some sort of self
questioning confidence issues that might
be entering into his head and compounded
with time pressure that could be a
dangerous force and there's some very
legitimate practical issues now f5 is a
big move for white because my pony fives
now defended and once I go f5 am I gonna
play nice it's am I gonna play f6
you know is your king Rose
f-five by John was not expecting that
and all and I mean I I don't dislike
this move it because he's trying to open
the position up he's got the extra
exchange and now office on Knight takes
f6 and he starts to talk to me that pawn
on e4 and half forth those pawns are
both a blessing and a curse
yeah Knight f6 you would like to get
your neck to h5 but the we need to
cover so I would play Knight to e5
perhaps for Alina protecting a 405
that's bold
they say fortune favors the bold right
yeah but I'm worried about queenie 8 and
therefore night at for coming oh he's
annoying yeah whoa 5 y 7 probably he
wants oh gosh I mean that just it scares
me to see very scary yeah yeah for sure
so Brooke everyone to protect on and 5
is this going out of control for John
but then 97 and I'm not if you can't
hold that e5 pawn you're in big trouble
yeah the Pawnee 5 totally pinned to this
run g3 and there you know you're
probably fives also under attacks in 97
I like your move then I'm 6 maybe but
that doesn't do anything G takes f6 and
that actually favors blocks that h7
Bishop is opened up I'm afraid that
Alina
I mean she's found some counter play but
it's it might just not be enough there's
an amount to anything
well done by John Doe f5 he found this
tactical shine seeing a pissant was
clearly something that backfired for
Alina if we poked you now support really
quickly we'll see that after f5 you know
by taking on f6 the position opens as
you're saying in Black's favor maybe if
you just played a quieter move like
Bishop to f3 or something just defending
the e4 pawn and saying that I like my
chain I have four and e5 it's limiting
blacks pieces they're restricted and so
of course black is better pretty much no
matter what but the game continuation
when things opened up the extra material
as clearly told the tale yeah I think
it's one of those cases where you
develop okay King of faith interesting
choice the power of the bishops on h7
and c7 yeah but I'm not sure but now I
guess I'm not I don't like King f8
that gives Y more chances
is that pond at age six is now I totally
forgot about that pawn I mean it's not
the pond that's important it's the King
safety but John's got to be careful here
King g7 maybe but then I take and go
Queen d7 check I'm sure it's still
winning in any case but but knowing I
will allow that the time King g7 there
would be night at 4:00 for the up like
you're just putting your King in a place
where the night comes in tonight if said
what a calm that's good John John John
but night at 4:00 okay Alena Alena
tightening the screws here Bishop comes
out to see for Mom KS this is starting
look scary actually Bishop c4 it's a
pain on the night and that New Year's
King is feeling uncomfortable 20 seconds
up for each player five in the mix yeah
9 th one looks really good while the
Queen da turn off the trick we have to
immediately watch out for Discovery's
the bishop sent some key on going really
well here he's defending against every
threat we need you to read Queen III to
go 94 and take over the e-file can use
one oh yeah John break in via all of the
reserves and whoa okay so do you have a
trade Queens at c7 Bishop the rook and a
fade from Seidman there's no follow up
that's the problem is it's only an
exchange though you know it's yeah you
can just play this position I mean look
at all of you know there's a lot of
latent tactical energy here I would play
whoa oh my gosh that looks like a scary
I don't like them at all
take out c5 over than b6 so don't play
Bishop e6 b 6 b 6 okay how do you defend
you probably oh you don't know
all right oh man what a move by John
John John John Man Man Man Man Man Man
Man Man Man now it's a one-point match
and John gets the white pieces that was
a big big big win by John I feel like
we're subconsciously repeating all the
words three times they should have four
so we had the same sort of Kramnik anti
Cadman lines least what I call it
because chromic was the king of the
cattle he wrote a book about his title
and games and my playing b5 you stop
white from playing c4 and so you get a
different dynamic all together where
white doesn't get the same activity
maybe at the cost of a pawn instead
you're just now playing a more solid
approach yeah I mean how did I'm trying
to remember so Lina won the first time
this happened or that past fought on c3
and like he said the dynamic of the
position is different I'm not in love
with the way John has handled this I
feel like Elena's more than solves all
their opening problems I think she's the
one contending for an edge here although
maybe I'm miss miss reading and miss
evaluating in this position I'd like
blacks position as well I think that
white of course is fine but it's not
about this current position I'm sure
that's what you're talking about you're
not saying Oh black is better right at
this moment but the question is what is
actually White's plan so she I couldn't
see you know the Queen that's
interesting why are you the Queen out
the bishop she knows what kind of Knight
b3 with tempo and Bishop e3 yeah I
suppose so and she wants more
flexibility in terms of where to put the
Queen eight four by John so if a six
that a five square is one thing that
Elena's gotta watch out for the idea of
going night b3 and then maybe not a five
at some point you know those positional
problems can creep up on you before but
Alina interesting c4 it there we go
Mitchell NG tube but this actually
doesn't have a huge threat because d5 is
so well defended by blacks pieces and
actually sometimes opening up the D file
is really bad for white when you get a
quick rook to d8 there it is and if you
take on d5 my knight gifts d5 official
on a4 is under attack there might be a
problem down the D file so I actually
don't like this kind of a4 b4 situation
for Wyatt and do some weak squares that
you have trouble protecting yes but one
thing to be cautious about for black
doesn't have an idea the CD 595 agency
Brian just in time but I was you know
more in the future but the problem now
is there might be no future at all
because the tension might be about it
might be released at some point either
34 or work AC 8 and blacks got all the
bases very safely covered here and d4
would be bad I think as a c5 oh right
yeah that's IP approach C is I'm sure
they now support really quickly but I'm
wouldn't you know d4 is a movie if you
can clog the c5 square yourself then d4
would be good but d4 c5 and the problem
is the Queen is overloaded protecting
the bishop and trying to stop the pond
so after Queen moves Bishop e7 or
actually c6 right over I think the pawn
just can't be stopped and goes to c7 and
everything falls
yep and now John trying to maintain
attention I am with you on the fact that
this a 4 B 4 that creates some
weaknesses for white that could
potentially make their presence felt now
the question is who is going to benefit
from all of this tension just visually
it does look good for black but just
like it's hard for white to find a plan
it's kind of this game of cat and mouse
who flinches first you want to play
Knight over to c5 in one move I dropped
an eye on c5 that just the square that
your knight belongs on but of course
can't do that with the knight being
pinned into the mission 1e 7 so that's a
bit frustrating Chi place h6 inviting
the exchange on f6 and ok the bishops
strong take with the pawn in in these
cattle and positions what I actually
eventually found out it sometimes looks
very good with that bishop but I had
some games where that Knight has a lot
of access to these squares on c5 and b5
so it's not as maybe one-sided as it
might seem not as innocuous as it might
say I should say and actually if the
Queen moves at the wave complete b3 and
lock tonight in a light awkward it shows
the nice dominance over Bishop because
efficient can only stay on its color
complex in this case the dark squares
and that's why I was thing about pawn
takes d5 instead of taken with a piece
on d5 because when there's a knight on D
2 and a pawn on d5 that pawn would have
fighted me to go back in time like a
pond 85 limits this Knights ability to
maneuver yeah and now we should point
out the Queen takes before meets with
rook t1 check and like picks off the
bought a fiber junk driving a wedge in I
kind of like the way this is transformed
for John olena trying to trying to work
a straight active counter plays h4 maybe
even better takes h4 h4 is not a very
John like move to allow visually or g5
is opening up the king but h4 for black
is this is the alpha 0 influence where
you see players I mean this is not just
AB students people been doing this for a
very long time but h4 makes it just to
make the white Kings I feel a little bit
less safe yep and Jon preparing Queen
takes before that has become a threat
which Alina has to be was she could deal
with that in them were in a variety of
ways Bishop e7 but you know I feel like
in her eyes she's got the small
initiative ok
p7 played John has also tied down to
that 85 points so that pawn is annoying
for black but it also ties white down we
see a lot of these things that are kind
of two-sided and the question is who is
going to solve the concrete problems of
their position John also lower on time
you're quite significantly and I want to
answer that question up before being
hanging just to show could you've made
the point I didn't show it on the board
that'd be for this roof d1 check you
have to take on d1 and after Queen takes
T 1 cubed Queen takes e 2 was the
problem so before was hanging but the e
2 point is more important as the White
King would feel very unsafe in that
transition correct
h4 by Lina here we go and you know you
might say well what is the threat
there's no immediate threat but you
pointed this out Robert it's just the
accumulation of small tactical ideas
that eventually come together and allow
some sort of a combination but John for
the time being holding everything
together even H Street shucks yep uh-oh
and there's time League Bishop c5
hitting f2 you just poking and prodding
looks like clock 20 walking up one I
would even consider taking it looking up
3 there Kiev when I didn't like it all
because never opting ones made if you
allow it oh my goodness and Kiko 93 but
now rock a5 was possible alina going for
the direct idea queen a to live here we
need to buy but the bishop of it you can
get away with it but it looks very
sketchy kids as it does she h7 might be
a smart move
yup I'm very much in the spirit of the
position just making sure all the bases
are covered because John really wants to
trade Queens here right
Quincy eight straight Queens to
safeguard the White King Bishop g5 is
probably tempting her as well
Jabez g60 allows the queen trade in King
g7 and take with the fish but now it
takes a 94 uh-huh and everything is
covered look at that night covering the
d2 pot and covering me at 573 okay I
thought my John gave that away honestly
but okay I can see what he's trying to
do the bishop stinks I mean it's sudden
we see for it so yeah over c1 look we
both have the same reaction MyKad we're
calculating the same stuff now but watch
out for route 64 yeah yeah you give up
oh because you won
Bishop do you want G 1 yep
in do i but now still so or OTP check
yeah no this is mp3s to collapse jets
not over yet whenever you have the night
you have calculated should you why here
no now takes that was a bad move Alina
this can't be winning any mcafee you
sure 57 so your give the F 7 point yeah
okay and it all together take it out
rook rook TC 6 King C 5 Brooke this
might be winning for white now oh my
gosh this is gonna be so unclear it's so
messy oh this is bad for black because
are you sure though king h3 be to have
five maybe John's getlist approaching
his paws he doesn't have forever but
there's got to be winning for white now
take each to each wing up six f5 meeting
the snake like pawns it's winning he's
seven are you sure though I'm not it's
not 25 f5 f6 oh look at Elena I was
tricky but here comes at 5:06 back King
on e5 is out shouldering its visa via
that's such a strong King and there we
go that's a painful loss for Lina wow
that was I mean Lina was winning yeah
she really wasn't reading this game I
feel like she played it too safe she
thought that she would have chances in
that rook endgame but all of a sudden
she had to decide to I sack the Potter -
I'll go for a draw and at that point her
ambitious instinct kind of went a little
bit too far what cool oven analysis
board because I want to show that moment
when she missed Bishop g1 and just the
way John was playing you he he had the
nine and c4 he had everything under
control and this new game I see is going
very quickly so I'll just show it just
first a quick second on the analysis
board from last game was it in his
position with f4 the promise Bishop g1
picks up h2 so she could've just gotten
away with that and then played on the
Queen side later
what she do is probably good but
unfortunately she was all in for the win
and then it results in the loss so now
there's night Kim's died 57 we saw 93 94
and E 5 last time for JB
do you think we're gonna see this again
I think we might and you said she was
all infra when I say she was all in
aleena for a win okay let's watch that
down no she's not gonna play Queen b3
again she's gonna
and I still think White's better here I
don't like that Bishop on h7 I feel like
in the long run the fact that it's out
of the game just it can't be good in
Queen c2 queen bee treats in easy
position to play for white but maybe
John has understood the a concrete ideas
of the position at first glance it
certainly looks better for white and
this decision to go rook a to d1 try to
f4 or kept tu one at the right moment to
expand but as soon as you try to play F
for the e4 square and the pawn that's on
it becomes more of a target
so King h1 maybe you want to go King h8
n f5 solve the problem that maybe Jon's
not concerned about that Bishop at all I
don't know wait even if you get that
move then why please f4 maybe even wife
I agree completely I also thought maybe
Bishop g8 + f6 but that also has its own
weaknesses
so maybe just have the possibility of
that open Bishop Jesus hilarious move
that you know often is a good idea but
it just looks so ridiculous thank you
Robert it means a lot to me no I
it's a I'm supporting it I think it's a
good choice but you know most people
would not willing I see I'm a
backpedaling the bishop would be
backpedaling but that's a good one
sushi f6 plate look at that Danya you're
100% correct Anna everything from the
moment John got out of bed this morning
put on that shirt I don't know we're on
the same wavelength Oh John and I like
Steve 5 whether he's coming he's wearing
the lucky midwestern flannel that's
worth upon completely agree a
compensation come besides yeah because
of this shot say yes but okay I can hear
my bomb go Vince is gone Romney could
say no but White was winning no but I
mean okay but I think no but somehow you
put the knight on d5 and okay
no but it doesn't matter the sacrifices
of might I think White's the Iranian you
got Bishop g4 here I mean it's gonna be
careful Knight c5 nicely fires happening
I think that for might have been
premature but I'm not sure maybe f5 I
give you suppose the d6 square in
Veneman 95 he's right I was thinking
about making that work but how I don't
know how about Bishop f3
mmm can we start calmly okay so what's
the next c4 all indices ooh well I think
only at home you come in a fruity eight
then I wasn't playing at five I like it
a lot but then the point concretely 95
Queen c2 rook at VA if you go 85 can you
just take on c3 take on e4 as well here
or after Bishop takes c3 she goes Queen
c4 I was a little concerned about this
move because of the possibility of
Bishop g8 but that's an oculus we need
to have a Bishop takes c3 okay BC then
Knight takes e4 no but why this video
maybe no but no but Robert I mean you
don't know what they're talking about
clearly white is winning oh my gosh this
is tilting I mean John was down two
games entering getting a portion and now
a Lina who is it's even right now but
once 98-94 I mean John is in the with
the advantage yeah no you're absolutely
right Knight takes g3 is of course Chuck
not that that's even necessary f5 can
support the night although I would be
careful about playing that move you're
absolutely right Oh Lina these tables
have turned imperceptibly all of a
sudden tied and John with the advantage
that's just how it works in these
matches but opposite colored bishop so
Lina crew still has plenty of chance to
survive a position like this and John is
thinking towards trade Queens no he
wants the 24 because if you look
at the quality when you've opposite
colored bishops right you think about
who has an attack who is the better
bishop the bishop on g3 would love to
get to d6 but that's just a skewer I'm
not gonna allow that to happen the
bishop on d5 is sort of a permanent
nuisance c4 though is what I mean it's
trying to accomplish next yep maybe
Queen f7 in that regard
but this is definitely not a one side of
the position I mean John John needs to
do some serious work here to win this
maybe queen c55 or Queen f7 I like both
those moves in Queens if I play look at
you Johnny king to JB I'm telling you
something about this morning something
about these shirts that started me off I
started being confident that I could put
wait a minute before I participate any
longer what if you just snap on c3 I was
thinking the same thing as Bishop takes
h6
they're a little bit too slow yeah I
don't really believe that now John
knowing John might do something like
bring the rook in rook a e8 but and if
he plays that boof that's gonna be
creepy no he takes Queen takes c3 he's
decided be greedy and smart and wears
whites even hope Queen g6 okay your
intentions are very clear sufficient of
seven you can kick the Queen out you
could play yeah Bishop f7 you could also
try to be cute but you don't want to be
cheeky and I thought something like
Queen c2 I knew you're gonna say that
and it broke t2 Queen c4 but John Big
John prudent fast he's got 30 seconds
gotta keep an eye on the clock and he's
probably looking at and worried a bit
about rook to d7 so he plays rook to d8
mm-hmm and where is White's counterplay
gonna come from h3 will play just two we
have the same reaction Gary takes and
rook t1 even that seems not why is to
give the default we need a 4/3 palm but
rook d7 so about the activity here and
looked at this time John less than 20
seconds oh we I'm looking already like
you said Bishop takes h6 Queeny Queeny
Queeny tuo Queen b1 and wait on five
that's the problem also King each two
for Alina maybe maybe just first just I
know it's a hard move to play but just
get rid of the checks then play with h4
Hey still not over Queen that fighters
rook d7 but you got a movie screen one
final two keys to take on at five to
play root 6 P 7 and Jon can just chill a
little bit
Queen qi6 King GA I think she missed
Queen B 1 because demanded time she's
spending right now indicates it you know
she wasn't ready for this response
absolutely and rook b7 that's an
important decision Bishop the King g8
Queen g3 to watch out for h6 and Bishop
d6 right visually 6600 therefore check
oh yeah
I brought we're literally discussing my
gosh oh man what a chance was that just
like good did Jon have any resources
there we're gonna have to bring it up
really quickly into overtime we'll keep
an eye on the live game but just
that one more time that was a hectic
finish and at the Queen g3 Kingston
Bishop e6 hits the rook the rook can't
move you lose the bishop in fact white
was winning in a position like that that
just is a missed opportunity for aleena
in a time scramble so back to the live
board Dania Johnny knows it too sorry
this is called the gossip variation I
didn't even know that it is and look
under chest icon thing
yeah gossip variation that's not real I
feel like they just made that I&C - well
I feel like they they followed a rumor
that that was what it was called but it
was a false rumor got a rumor has it you
no no I got it
you know I didn't want to get me gossip
girl jokes I decided to change the
subject and 97 so there's a lot of
tension on e4 and e5 here I mean Daniel
now JB is a point ahead in the match
so advantage JB yes I mean that's
especially tilting I mean - Lina would
that Bishop d6 chance I think she in her
mind though she you know she gave up a
little bit which is not something she
does I don't mean she actually gave up
but I think she herself didn't believe
that John would let that out of the cage
now John up by one point yeah I mean
Elena's gotta just you know she's not
playing badly
she's not doing anything globally wrong
she's just got to play a little bit
faster with a little bit more confidence
here and um you know the match can swing
again and she's moving forward in the
center here with her d5 again playing
fast mm-hmm playing very quickly she can
just play c6 to defend that pawn on d5
can consider playing efore she was 27
I'm a little concerned about this pawn
on d5 but maybe there's no way to move
the knight because where's the 93 ignore
the e1 or c1 at doesn't look like a good
move
John of the alpha 0 a 4 I feel like
that's the move we default so he used to
be king h4 and now it's a4 a5 when
there's when we don't know what to do
just play a 4h 4 so a fun does he really
want to play a six or that doesn't
really seem to do much
well maybe Queens c3 preparing a save so
though that's so artificial that's
painfully artificial then he takes d4
he's gonna play rook e1 I think so
get the one and then at what point is
black just like efore then go g5 and
push all the pawns
this is uncanny I feel I feel confident
now that I can predict asthma you feel
confident in yourself or in John in this
match well knowing my own quality of
play I'm not confident in John's
abilities and I think it's a great thing
that I'm predicting some of his moves
but I like rookie one because okay see
three very solid I like blacks position
oh yeah definitely
right yeah do you play c5 at some point
that weakens the d5 pawn so I actually
wanted my opponent g5 and then put my
bishop on g6 to play h5 I would love to
expand more on the King side but h5 now
it feels a bit mmm dubious just because
it doesn't have a threat oh my god I'm
telling you that's just what people do
so what is going on are you like
preparing flash telepathy with John and
you're Elena that's crazy
I feel bad for Lena because you know
having the same thoughts as me and the
chess board what I do you've got to
watch out D takes e5 and knight c6
Bishop takes e5 though yeah but I
understand but then still I see six
takes takes and Queen e6 at baby Bishop
c4 you brought two variations I gotta
get you know I got a pub the analysis
board just so you can get there's a d5
instead of h4 s what you were saying
and after d5 f e5 Bishop e5 using knight
c6 yep
Knight takes Queen d5 queenie 6p takes
the Queen and Bishop c4 you have two
pawns I'm not sure what to make of that
position and John of course doesn't do
it but now the current d1 from John he's
attacking that pawn and Robert wise
words yes he doesn't Queen f5 loses to
Bishop d3 we had five Bishop e3 that
well then you can't force a queen of
seven protects Oh safe and sound
your ship f3 star massaging he sees that
idea of Knight 66 I'm telling you that's
and maybe move the King away if you're
Alina so King h7 or King h8 yeah but I
do
I feel like it
the tenor of this game has turned to
John do you agree oh that I completely
agree and the other move that I'm
thinking buddy eight potentially just to
protect d5 by alive Mike Bishop to take
on e5 where my rook will then be an
additional defender but I'm yes this not
seeming great for Lina because she can't
take on b4 just see things before she
first King h8 avoiding some of these
knight c6 stuff right
but it's also not easy to see what white
does yeah you've gotta find a move here
you don't want to play it you're on with
the Queen away from d1 because it's
tying down the Queen and f7 maybe just
bide time of the rook see one but that's
not a satisfying move and then that up
that a6 fun is also in the mix yes
here's the rate goes English one King h1
just you know okay but should be too and
there's rip d8 so that's a sensible move
there's me too by the way protecting a
six
even though basic spawn is defended
doesn't away can be attacked just so you
can free your rook away from c1
alright now you can rook e8 maybe just
her 97 yeah and now I would play John
stead of consider Eve for but the
problem there is black takes and goes
out five
what if they repeat moves Knight B 898
I'm not that'd be hilarious don't think
it's happening but that would be a
really funny repetition okay John's
gotta watch this clock too because this
time it's a very hard position that
Keith would be for oh gosh Oh III that
would have been very strong move as
Queen away John's gotta move as Queen
back before we get over oh my goodness
now it's stronger yeah you're winning a
pawn on g3 okay but are you there's h5
ah
you sneaky sneaky man I would even play
my bum
maybe a five-night f6 or does okay yep
so nice coming in but cook it on here
I don't like Queen up to it that's okay
but job planning that Queen there and
now he's preparing c4 so weird can Alina
made progress c3 now
c5 placing yeah she had to play c5 now
John gets a chance taking place he five
take up came the night cake comes out to
d5 maybe nine of six she's painting
to safely that's a good move Queenie
five weaponizing the Queen and the rook
on c8 needs the defense of the Queen in
Queen d7 there's already CD and bikes
Center starts to crumble
now Elena's starting to dip down on the
clock rook e8 Oh baby play 48 yeah
but then yeah I feel like that's the
lesser evil then John's gonna take take
and give a check on see you soon again
sometime okay she flits at four seconds
take take take
keep taking a look see a drop see one
double alright King h7 rip c1 nice
you're finding it thank you for watch
every grain of Elena g5 I was thinking a
g5 to just push that pond open up the
King now John's got this plane he's
gonna bring his king to e2 and he's
gonna play Ruby Seminole Ian's got no
time she's got to do something Knight g4
that we might see a weird repetition Oh
Knight d7 John's gonna go for a get take
it in group TG 3d oh now it takes a 95 a
let's force nasty and forth nasty Oh
Elena's just explained to passengers
that Paul look at that pawn on e6
that pawns becoming a queen Elena's
gotta find a drawsome so she's she
trying for that mechanism you know a
root each unit of three so John's gotta
go for a 95 Oh Brooks King t1 an 87 of M
squared H is defended so go rook g1
right now yes and roof c1 yes what do
you want you have to only move Lin's got
a move
still okay okay one but King be 295
Knight b6 another idea that wins the
game and at four and four
she's got a knight c6 with PA she still
has some chances for k1 is the king
checkmate no no yeah so jus but takes
and go rook see what I mean force him to
meet you or I'd lose some time well at a
game Wow well that was winning another
one that is got to be so tilting for
Alina that was electric
incredible incredible tension and John
with five seconds on the clock
kudos to John II found just I mean he
was more direct and more decisive than
Elena I think Alina vacillated in terms
of what plan to choose and you know
things were going her way but she
hesitated too much and it's fascinating
in this three-minute portion John is won
all four games thus far because that one
was a total toss-up we thought that you
know John was you know really
putting pressure on some square see six
upon a six essentially was became a
queen but it felt like Alina was
handling it very well she got to e4
bridge she's stuck on g3 but somehow I
wonder if she felt like she should be
better as I did I was saying oh whoa
g4 by the way I was think she must be
better and then it wasn't easy to
actually figure out so now g4 clay by
Lina and I'm not I don't think she's
tilting I think it's a good move no
she's she's playing fast and she's
consciously decided to play faster which
is the correct thing to do the time
really has cost her in this John has
been handling these acute time scrambles
a little bit better than Alina John is
playing incredibly well in a cute time
pressure which impresses me always but
this is amazing for Alina no I like it
for sure that bishop on c4 it doesn't
have a counterpart so opening up some of
these light squares King G to rook H one
comes to mind but at some point maybe
there's some Bishop takes c3 going to be
going to the e4 square for JB yeah Kim G
- there we go John whisper your rook H
one Queen - the H file that's of course
an idea how does white accomplish
everything is it just that simple you
play rook H one and queen at four pawn
f3 Queen h6 and just go checkmate
no but somehow I think yeah I'm in some
car wipers being in the other hand I
would say wreck h1 is obligatory the
thing is that maybe John takes on c3 and
goes Queenie for whoa weren't expecting
that were ya that's interesting because
he's trying to turn it back on white so
gh9 h5 the province there's this one
check on g5 Robert but the king can tuck
itself away on f1 doesn't even allow
that taking away the g5 square gaining
more space limiting the black pieces the
97 would love to go to e5 so I'm
thinking c5 maneuvers he can't because
the white knight comes in the d5 but my
point was fc5 95 all of a sudden blacks
pieces are jumping into the position but
as mentioned c5 just gives up the d5
square so in lieu of that q g7
rookie she feels a bit slow yeah but if
you don't do that that g6 phone is also
potentially hanging just Oh
John threatens Bishop c3 and Queenie for
not that that end game is even bad for
white but I would I would consider a
five I would consider Bishop h6 yep
there
it's like you want rate pieces I'm down
for it but Bishop seats f8 whatever
these actually exchange it's not a
threat because Queen g5 check oh look at
you I'm just you know trying to take a
little lesson from you every now and
then Queen h4 never I was done working
yep there's just enough there's not
enough activity here right look at these
pieces the night on d7 I mean I highly
developed pieces just not doing much of
anything
yep now and there's just gotta be me
know cold-blooded here maybe um okay
that's it that's a very devious move you
can't play Queen h3 because of Queen 64
maybe you can but that's unnecessary
complications right you wanna play rook
h1 Queen h3 go meet them the H file but
your bishop on c4 is under attack and
you know figure it all out
that's a great move because g5 is also
an idea let's say Alina plays Queen d3
John can try to go g5 or night h5 that
Queen on f6 is very strong all of a
sudden yeah
unexpected moves like that they really
cause you to tilt so II five eggs she
transforms her advantage I I don't
dislike that idea where does your night
go Knight g4 will get your night trap
because I'll move my bishop away and
then aha probably when you're nice and
97 HR you're I've I mean these Knights
are just so clumsy they are really
clumsy I mean John's holding on and
there's at some point you can consider
an exchange sack with mattify I know
it's desperate but Elena's Center is not
exactly you know very well defended and
you know how Knights are their passive
1seg and all of a sudden they
coordinated and you're in trouble the
next yes they're frustrating pieces
especially in the bullet game so rookie
4 comes to mind to protect e4
preemptively and stop your Knights men
night and for
look d1 butts more passionately let a
little bit of her advantage slip and I
think Elena's experiencing some
frustration look at the time the time is
equalized this is nerve-racking her
position is great though definitely
without a doubt but
this is a this is basically a must-win
from a second watch me five can I can i
play bamboo just push my pawn through
hey I actually liked it
okay Rock h1 is not bad I think yeah you
can go row cage for two but then 9 to 5
so they actually Ridge forward be a bad
move rookie 4
okay rope t1 I liked rookie for earlier
but I guess rookie one supports d5
indeed I would consider Knight f5 now
honestly I know that's in total
desperation but at least for some air at
least some activity oh okay
so dv5 still tempting me
but she's right up his night wait oh you
can't take it because f7 pawn is problem
there we go I want to somehow second h5
but yeah how maybe Bishop e3 maybe it's
time to just dip back a little bit White
is still better but it her advantage
keeps evaporating and our time advantage
so does her time it was once out twenty
seconds or so now it's she down about to
be 20 seconds oh my goodness so Bishop
e3 is a nice retreating move and she
plays it it's hard moved to play so I'm
actually proud of her for even you know
binding it and well you don't want to
take on e3 because now you three fe3 yes
you double the pawns with the f7 pawn
it's a weakness it should eat sue gone
right for that night that is he look at
the dishes look at how her he switches
from tactics to positional pressure
that's very hard to do as you point out
rubber I'm I'm shocked because I was
looking at the f7 square all in she was
back with Bishop to e3 back to mr. e
tuna Bishop g4 the reading Bishop takes
f5 said please take me on e3 I'll take
with my F pawn your knight own h5 is
dominated he might have to don't see if
Bishop takes f5
okay now d5 okay it's still going see
the Iraqi six though which who thinks f5
coming all bishop
no but then moving to five rook a 5 and
a 5 in 1985 was hanging but this little
cage I know this is crushing though look
at the mating ideas - I don't even see
move takes aware how did how where is
the mate is you guys ship a try
no but you e2 it was better ok now can
you
John still holding on that f6 coming Oh
Knight g4 look at how blacks pieces
cords Nate oh my god oh my goodness no
everything that could go wrong is going
wrong because before I got I tried
before what she's going after the beat
ball and she blows over some - oh my
goodness yeah this is this is not going
her way at this point and John I mean
cool as a cucumber they're unbelievable
so the knight was hanging on g5 for
several moves and then all of a sudden
White was seemingly crashing through but
John doesn't give up he found that cool
move rook h6 and survived and man that's
made me a man
man man man and John you know you have
no idea once again if he's down eight
points or he's won six games in a row
which has been the case for five games
in a row and that is I mean Elena's just
she's just losing her cool a little bit
in those time scrambles and yes Jon
missed the free piece but that also does
happen I mean we always say this and we
always mean it commentating from the
side watching them is stuck how could
they miss that it's so obvious but you
don't know where his mind is that he's
not expecting Melina to blunder a piece
right and he's been playing the entire
we're talking about specific concepts
within the game every single move both
John and Alina they're like wait if I go
this this one happened they're thinking
you bunch of moves down the line whereas
if we make a blunder we just press the
back button and say oops my bad balls a
big blunder hey the game's over there
goes your exchange there goes your
Bishop naive to resign so in this
position now that we've entered this
game I like her position again from the
black side so somehow these JB openings
I really don't feel like they're going
his way
no he feels comfortable so even if the
objective evaluation is saying that
black is doing pretty well I guess John
is enjoying the positions nonetheless
yeah and you know he's playing this kind
of bunker style chess where Elena's got
the space advantage and he's also
playing a psychological game when you
keep watching good positions well it's
almost like you don't want to get a good
position because you've got to get
desire
we go again I'm gonna find a way to
botch this I do that all the time yeah
you know even when I'm streaming I
always say that I keep getting in
position to keep watching it you know
you start playing psychological tricks
on yourself and another thing to point
out in the previous game night takes III
was always a bad move
so maybe John kind of just forgot that
it exists she assumed that it would
always be a bad move and that sometimes
is the reason you miss easy chances
because it's a move that previously was
really bad
that's right so yeah you're again it
looks like John's recovered from some
opening problems maybe I'll do you
weren't capturing Bishop e5 and F takes
the end so the big one h5 is just in a
weird spot but probably in a good one
Queen d6 at the right moment will be a
problem for block to deal with just
because the bishop and the pawn are
under attack may just rook a to D one to
start with 26 first and now oh what a
trick we need five there's recap 1 Shaq
of course that's awesome but it's a move
on blunder
nope don't you didn't and you also the
word of Bishop g4 like these bishop
discoveries so for JB it's not a fun
move to face Bishop e2 we look up du was
there some discoveries what you're
saying yes I was looking for but I guess
Devers dropped the Queen back yeah what
about okay so Brooke up one is possible
here well it's a double-edged position
John's got some tactical problems but
he's also got the static advantage of
that Queen position and blacks big
weakness on e5 it's a Bishop c4 and she
plays Bishop d4 is that Queen somewhat
trapped or something interesting mm very
interesting concept I don't see a good
response for white off the bat so rook
f6 rook f6 Queen d8 check and take on it
couldn't do that or you could play Queen
c5 give up before but it's so annoying
for John that he can't take on e5 at any
point he does exactly what you said
so maybe now we're gonna switch advice
and that might be bad for John if he's
listening to my lines
exactly
but I actually think this is good see
black has the past pawn and it's easy to
be blinded by it but that outside pawn
majority white has I'm telling you
John's a blonde could eventually decide
the game yeah b4 c4 b 585 all this stuff
pushed upon another board and especially
end games if you can envision I know
this isn't always easy envision the
Queen's off the board
and then you start thinking the King
will become an active piece but if I
have an outside passed pawn the black
King left to run all the way to the
Queen side and what's the Queen the king
is distracted over there then White's
King will start moving up the board in
the Kings side I'm gonna make you proud
you know what I noticed about that a
pawn what it's the same color as the
bishop oh my gosh I'd really like that
actually I've started to do that between
a check yeah great what did I tell you
okay bam bam what Quan would decide the
game unless he doesn't see it he does
time so Alina Chi has a chance because
it the Queen if you go to 85 carelessly
Queen at 4 Queen b6 oh you could say
okay well it's not that but then Queen
c1 I know what you're saying I agree and
25 seconds left for John so even though
he's in the drivers scene right now the
black queen is is more active in the
sense that it actually attacks the white
king
18:17 he goes Queen b6 which is a good
move but he's spending a lot of time to
find that good move
yep Queen up 4 and there we see it play
out I would start pushing them I'm not
sure about that because now black gets
active counter plan that eight pawns not
gonna be as easy to guide through
although he could push it to a6 it's
gonna be defended by the bishop but some
43 ideas by black that's what I was
gonna say Queen c1 I get but should be
three in there and you have this pin D
to deal with permanently and no matter
how you make left for your king there
are some issues Queen e2 so Queen
there's no really good move here yeah
good move
that's a great move by John Queen apply
of e5 King a5 even a GG for king of for
maybe okay you just go for I think John
very prudent a fight he doesn't even
look for it don't need to go for
adventures with you for my g4 allows the
King in the bishop to f3 things like
that so a 5 can she stop this pawn
she'll my c5 at some moment to give her
Bishop the length of diagonal but when
you play c5 and you're probably lose the
C pawn in addition to having the
struggle against to a pawn
yeah and there's no hurry I mean John
can plant the pawn on e6 and then do
something like h3 you could improve his
position until he's ready to go a7 he
does it
c4 immediately so busy g4 a 6 and queen
up two and a 7 I guess but then again
that Bishop d3 move I think he's missed
it
yuki 6 just go pick up 308 75388 Queen
oh that's nasty
but John going here first I guess that
makes sense as well and then c5 TV you
played right just a Queenie through
that's such a good move because the
bishop now has to go to g6 for example
but you just need to make the move I
understand her position is bad but ue4
trying to boost outsmart and King up to
Queen B - I'm letting the Queen's tied
down that's what kills black here and
the run B C to see me on such a
bad square cos Queen takes PC would have
been checking out before even a Bishop
e2 look at John I mean he's so
methodical he never rushes he's so hard
to bring down doesn't blunder that often
before your move Queen f5 check to
strike two kings back from g1 no more
checks should go three doesn't matter -
it doesn't be six or or even Queen and
Bishop takes c3 because the King was
bent but this works she's distracting
and winning on time and time is up by
the way so we just saw John
sweep leave three Minotaur ssin
incredible he went from minus 2 to plus
4 we only have the bullet portion
remaining of this I am none of GM
speechless champion match brought to you
by chess calm and Danya any predictions
or I mean it feels like it's all going
John's way well the alina needs this
break she'll take some deep breath it is
going John's way but all I'm gonna say
is I think Elena's got a couple of
uppercut throws in her so don't go
anywhere we will be right back
[Music]
and as we return we see that JB has not
been a part of any close matches as far
this one being his closest and aleena on
the other hand she had two close matches
in the first two rounds and in the
semies she ended up dominating so Danya
JB's up four points which is a huge lead
he just swept the three-minute portion
does he need to be careful a little bit
just not to you know I says you put the
cart before the horse and think I had
this match under my control
because Lina is a dangerous bullet
player absolutely and I think the first
one or two games you know are pivotal
because if John can strike while the
iron is sought if you can deliver
another blow you know Elena might think
I here we go with this again yes we I
think we've discussed the you know four
is that sort of critical mass if your
lead in the bullet section is five or
above that just makes it mathematically
difficult to recover but let's say Elena
wins the first wins the first two all of
a sudden it's a two-point game and
there's 15 minutes left
you know I feel like the importance of
this bullet portion and the results of
the match might be determined in the
first two games yeah Danny wrench came
four games down and stormed back against
Teddy Coleman and eventually lost in the
tiebreak you know for me a mini match
but it's possible we've seen it happen
and Alena
once you put arrows in she was tied and
then won by five because of her bullet
skills so let's get these games on you
know let's give them on her way because
the file section we're still excited
here JB you know he's got a four game
cushion but can't get complacent because
that's the way you lose a match that you
really shouldn't at this point exactly
and here we here we go Alena with the
white thesis here
Elena's got to be confident she played
well in a five minute portion she's got
to get out of her head you know John
played an incredible three minute or
ssin but that doesn't mean you know
Alena has to keep losing we know how
these matches go the fortunes can change
with one well played game and when you
have a husband who is when a storm of
chess players in the planet maybe you
could just go in there
through I'm gonna get a little advice
well maybe not page to hanging yeah
that's a known little traveling you
looks like you're winning some pollens
but the meantime you're losing your old
Queen said well it's gonna say dunya and
I know you know that I got changed of it
really quickly is that during the breaks
you can go and say hey Roddick what
should I do you know is there any kind
of dangerous opening that I can play it
specifically for bullet and it's pretty
good advice to get and so Brooke at so
she's up a piece now night of one coming
in radical rook each one there and Queen
up to was interesting she's thinking
radical measures don't don't do it Diana
they did the rook each one was a
beautiful move though and whenever - I
feel like now Elena's got on the basis
courage you can just continue her
development Bishop d2 rookie one we need
three Queen g5 but now jump could take
c4 and he's gonna have three pawns I
don't like Queen b3 I don't like this
because now he can take him to a 9500
takes in Bishop g5 to g5 yeah oh that's
a big one and she's got to convert this
but John's got a lot of puns how many's
at four pawns or I mean it's not over
but it's of course completely winning
four right rook double rocks tricky 493
coming just trade on pieces go after the
open mind that was not good by John John
miss a lot of stuff there he had a lot
of chances in this is the exactly
million each she was the one who was
blundering quite a bit in the previous
side control yeah now rookie four I
guess was good king g3 almost wraps the
rook
leave g5 oh I don't know if I would have
blended a page three the rook is
cornered it's still not over but
whenever you have that many pastors now
t4 if John can get t4 and oh let me tell
you Robert this is not easy at all no
because you came to me rook up the D
file otherwise g4 happens and you
probably have to let it you know happen
but ooh it's almost Souza Vaughn fur for
job at d4 pinky - Katie - no she's gonna
forget said okay I said okay seven I see
sorry do not take it up don't take it
there we go Kingston wants the last
little finesse you needed because you're
winning up seven you winning g77 check
with the bishop it's time what a game
Alena
rookie said her composure striking back
bishop me Oh Jake's okay rotates she
okay mister t5 now probably yes you guy
yeah
John can try see to but it's there's not
enough good resilience by John for sure
but and of course he needs to believe
the clock and the coach time she has by
the way crazy
what are you sick - Brooke be seven
total any of time so you to be careful
not to blow d2 phone me see things be to
it I mean it was still fine because a
bishop before but monka s okay thanks 46
and it's not fusions in AC three Casey
three the 94 comes but now King t - ÿà
kinky - and that's still games evil king
c for amazing rook g8 right yeah but the
problem is that's gonna take a while
don't blunder a for two seconds King III
D - you can't take on D - but you can v
very nice and I'm we can't take on D -
you know you have six still go yeah
finally can take on detail yeah now at
long last
just take the pawns you 20 seconds left
f7 in 1978 a tricky move rook da go Rudy
a clean take then take the rook and play
jobs gotta play this out you're right
you can right now resign here because
there's always possibility of a fork in
next e5 check knight back to e6 okay not
qui be safe way mistakes picked off the
night Alina
okay there's still no resign you might
whole wait right all right we waste
another 22nd and that's it that's
something that um people don't realize
this isn't dirty or bad practice it's a
match there's a limited time in this
match and John graciously resides here
but that bled some clock that really did
he brought another like 40 seconds at
that point and right now John's the
white pieces but
Alina has had some really large time
advantages in the longer time patrols in
the early stages of the game so she has
tend to be pretty well prepared
John similarly has gotten to position
that he goes comfortable in but Alina
and that booth skate in between a bullet
game 240 seconds is a 8 seconds what was
that I was crazy very confident and
Elena covering all the bases well John's
got up you know Elena's still playing
fast I think in Elena's mind she's going
all it and she's saying I'm gonna play
fast I'm gonna try to win these games
fast I'm down by 4
it's already now that four point lead
has shifted to three I'm telling you
John is probably feeling a little bit
nervous that Queen on at five by the way
g6 is a huge threat
oh my goodness which is trapping the
Queen in h5 so now g6 and now you see
two g6 I think you of Quinnie threes
missed it Queen at home my god geez but
no f6 f6 key G said oh what a win for
John's gotta give that give that pawn up
yep Bishop takes e5 just win that pawn
Lina's I mean that domina positional
dominance - oh my gosh Queen a 392 is
coming yeah okay John finding the best
way to keep going and she gonna play
that for it no 96 keeping that she's
more space she's one make a trade yup
good move
you have to take right because after you
come otherwise but now the e-file gives
white some chances so Rick f7 rookie 6
then rook it 92 it yeah I mean for to
trade that Queen off John wants to put a
knight on d4 not sure over 94 in 94 you
have to the f3 of 300 and 96 comes in
like g4 c5 c3 365 26 right so yes
oh no there's there's there's a pin
Elena's blundered in 96 Jack 96 no
matter what oh my goodness Alina playing
a little bit too fast there so there's
nothing there's nothing be three doesn't
even help why just ignores goes 96 check
yep unbelievable resilience by John so
use resign here or do you try to hold
you play no you and there's it's not
lost enough I would play that's true if
it's after Queen f6 rook if six you take
on a fake King takes to fate
you actually have woo she's taking this
fun I like I like that decision yeah
that's even better the Knights in
trouble what okay Queen Queen vive and
LA yeah Queen d5 Knight c3 okay
Queen da and night a fake by the way is
interesting but I wouldn't go for that
oh that's filthy by John but Vanessa the
Queen ease the move and it can't stay
with the pin and rook takes e1 sounds
very prudent move though because Queen
c3 and John's gonna bleed another she
should never lose this game even if you
draw
after three more minutes I mean that's
that's not something Elena can afford
she can't lose the skin she has to pull
out a draw here and it's going to be
very difficult because we are a pond and
the kid
okay so rookie eight responsible they're
actually Queen at for Ricky eight
because the Queen is tied to the c7 run
nice man tactically sharpened name a man
age four look at John jizz crunching
through flexed offenses here
chiseling his way into blacks King Paul
I'd like that move though I do between
age seven potentially g4 is what I would
consider your queen d6 okay each five
doesn't work so I'm not opening the
gates that's a good let's not see said
idea that's a great idea
just keeping the get the Queen's off and
go to the endgame it just worries me
that the time keeps ticking although
this should be hole double for black if
Elena just begs her rook to the eight
for pawn I don't see a way to make
progress well teach you for now oh no
then judge you to Hanks ah of course of
course I actually thought that too John
need to push his pawn to g3 and then try
to go Kings you for the promise is no
rook c5 check so the King can't be
kicking what does I'm gonna do okay rook
a3 is very precise
now just came back yeah and reduced you
yeah I wouldn't even play up for at some
point just keep playing might as well as
long as you can play forever
rook if two men came Brooke III okay at
four yeah we're just yep take taking g5
and make another 50 moves here if if
buck ever goes with g3 you go rook d7
you go to room T 7 you got to be careful
and um yeah it's back in time doesn't oh
oh look at John very true this is not
easy
king of seems okay Keeney 7 oh that was
a nice move actually it was now cutting
up both Kings are cut off Lulu she's
over there
rookies you know isn't what kind of
playing for yeah kingi 485 bucks t 555
no wonder all my goodness you need to
keep howdy winning for white rook c1
yeah this is winning oh no and the king
is cut off to to add insult to injury
this is a Lucena the worst of the worst
for black is now
in spec and she has lost you have to
resign here he did save the time but
this is they'll be back to a four-game
lead and with only 15 minutes left
they're still Titan CEO John that was
again she won a pawn in the opening she
did and that was just overwhelming
pressure but John he minimized the
damage I feel like Alina thought I was
about to trap the Queen and it's
sometimes hard to switch from that to
okay now I have to win a long position
yeah and then she just got in trouble in
the dark squares right her King was
exposed she wouldn't have for you
criticize that move it's one that's
actually just weakens her a bit too much
and actually that's what backfired so
she's like very shouldn't mean it need
seconds yeah
and it's more of a bullet thing which I
criticize I'm not sure that was globally
a bad move objectively but in bullet you
just don't want to make unnecessary
weaknesses especially when you're trying
to play fast and take on c6 at some
point okay just you want to get c6 black
will take with the b-pawn you don't want
to allow the white 90 to d5 yeah there
is still enough time to mount a comeback
but Elena's got to win every single game
one more draw one more loss one more
very long game and the match is
basically over okay Queen f2 pins the
knight but the Queen before the medayto
right so I went extremely well
let's not let's be clear about that her
quality of play in the bullet is so far
has been great but you know it's just
not enough it has not she was out four
games to start with that was the real
issue is this not enough time left in
the in the match when you doubt four
games you win every single game more or
less and then she went all in and lost
yeah and this again her advantage seems
to have evaporated at four just go at
four look at her she still has a minute
on her clock and you believe that Robert
twenty seven moves in she's so fast that
is crazy
so Bishop e6 so just keeping him direct
left h5 Bishop a5 kind of stuff
H are played by wow I don't know what
that move by John I mean this King on h7
in some trouble here I hope the Queen h6
defend my king yep got to do it
again in the interest of the time now if
you taking GCC's 595 - but dish about
five it's not so clear just like we oh
okay okay
takes an h5 book and writing that wegend
don't go route c1 that's if you've won
the place of macho that's why yeah
that's why I said it I heard it's
natural to get the right to the open
paulina trying to drive h6g three g3f
for trap the queen you know just this
queen g5 quickly win the game Newman's
h6 maybe g6 ages have another idea
oh yeah though I didn't want to push my
pawn too far as a 93 where's the night
going Bishop e6 is the idea Petronas the
counting the seconds now there should be
six good idea just making that King feel
more vulnerable night at five six maybe
six okay bees a free piece but Queen e7
and stuff is coming as well h6 resigns
come on do it on it up Queen f7 played a
little bit too hesitant here yeah she's
she's gotten on her head a little bit I
think now what she won still doesn't
work there's a queen covering the square
careful Robin was correct
maybe she wants to give the H point and
meet on each file
yeah but then John my mate on the G file
that's the problem
no yeah that's true but I'm seeing he's
quitting mh6
oh no wait it's an eye travel there's a
million checks this is to Queen net for
g3 so Queen c6 head there has to be some
me queen f8 in 97 is one idea but that's
again too slow h6 maybe yeah Quinta 897
is probably oh gosh did you fight
where's the mate Nike Denny's for
nothing kingi Queen g7 no that's not the
way Mike yeah oh you tried witness babe
oh that's such a weird made what a man
oh my god finally checked me to show but
it's too long
she's 11 half minutes for three games
you know that that's that's definitely
doable it's doable but again one of the
games has to be it fast win
one about easy games has to be a fast
man we're first of all assuming she's
gonna win three games in a row against
John which I don't think John has lost
three games in his in a row in his
career the hardest players to make a
comeback against because he just never
beats himself he doesn't and he made her
gonna beat him into the very end there
like he almost escaped with his king and
she found queenie takes checkmate that
quickly because if the king ran away to
e3 all of a sudden like wait how do I
win this game to get frustrated here we
see a qgd turn into an open kind of a
qga in a sense
and now the bishops for white looked
very good here but there's some squares
on the Queen side that White has to keep
in mind and well he's nice but there are
some squares black has to keep in mind
b6 being foremost among them and look at
John going for a very solid line Queen
e2 this is just gonna be so hard to win
for Black Knight f5 Elina she's doing
the right thing sheesh I know unbalance
the position she has nothing to lose
gotta take all the risks in the world
John's gonna go back to g3 I think and
he's just gonna chill so then queenie 6
has been Queen f6 a knight should even
met by e4 yeah I think John's thinking
about doing something crazy like 96 but
here we see it
it's a knight back and he for not
possible because White has the square
under control and rook e8 now I think
Queen 6 was better but I mean at the end
of the world ok Elena banking on the
clock which I really like
look at John taking way too long here
he's well he's looking after Knight f4
is that a possibility for black coming
next was naive or I would take think
next III I'd see 3 I love it themself to
the night this is looking bad for Alina
now sera Boleyn no but h3 then how is
black even gonna angle herself just rip
the eight here right yeah but h3 we
never budge g6 open e 5 oh no pretty far
that's John is looking so well in time
pressure it's crazy and he's 16 seconds
up so he's saying I have plenty of time
left don't worry about me guys man I
don't know what to do I need some kind
of yes is correct I think but h3 John's
gonna just make it oh but Ricky 7 then
and he stops it so Fisher of three
there's no
move that really works does it yeah
Lina's gotta try some hacky tricks here
look back to d7 but John Berryman ride
moves
yeah it's nice he for back John can make
a draw here but he's of course playing
for the witness he should bring the rook
back and then play d4 and the Queen 68
yeah before there was maybe Knight f6
right you mean f8 okay okay oh oh
Biggs f3 rugby sevens yeah when you have
chances because the king is gather
locally right absolutely so roof 67 year
oh no but she's not gonna win this
position no definitely not
maybe she mean maybe that bond on d2 I
would not count her out here rook to
she's gotta do it just go for it Elena
okay physics first probably smart yeah
geez sakes but Knight c5 we can he 6v6
oh okay she goes up I didn't like that
now look up seven okay seven everything
is cleaned out let John rook c5 check
works t5 it was the last punch she could
have used to win the game potentially
but now rook c5 is still rook c5 again
found in John that is a clincher there
we go
and with that eight minutes left four
point lead once more this means a jump
our thumb you unless he loses you know
the next three games in a minute each he
is going to be the I am well he's just
di M is the I am not super I am I think
here to be fair for the winner of this
championship we should remove the nada
GM he deserves it so just this i am just
i am i am chess championship how about
super iron can he bestowed that title
and Lud's miss though that's at home
there will be some bestowed going on
it's shocking though considering what
happened earlier where you know john was
down two games after the five minute and
he swept the three minute right yeah I
mean he she's crazy you know and John I
mean the thing is and first of all let's
be clear here the match is never over
until there's zero zero zero left on the
clock but we're just being practical
here
another thing is John it's not only that
he's very composed right it's not only
that he's very composed that he's hard
to be he's also I mean he's not just
sitting there doing nothing I want to be
clear that he's incredibly tactically
sharp too and he always plays for win so
he's got that combination of qualities
that not only makes you strong player
it makes you an incredibly strong match
player and he's shown all of those
qualities here yeah and where you see
this vision when I have to now where the
sight made you see each fixture is that
something just take that pawn because
then I don't have six is under attack
um okay they're looking a missed shot
right yeah but now I got John with 20
seconds and he's shown time and time
again is it how about Bishop see 783 oh
my god you're just you but the Queen I
can see through this is very dangerous
because now it is okay Bishop takes each
six like just loosen up the King side
just if it doesn't work but just try it
maybe rook d7 here hope that you take me
so much is Robin what us that is fill
famous wait maybe Bishop c7 next maybe
one trap the Queen anyway yeah I still
but then the Queen is the e 7 squared
something faster she's gotta win this
game within 10 seconds here yeah rook d7
player Queen e2 going hard she wants
Bishop h6 but that's not even a threat
because the bishop comes back to f8 I
think right so 93 7 is we're gathered
yeah I thinks it's all John I mean he's
just outdoing himself game after game
here Brooke f1 Oh would be for
what a nice move wait sacré nice traffic
we didn't serve it it's a threat did I
oh and John sees that too it's just
everything no he sees every as I say in
my streams when I'm tilted which is
basically every c7 Queen d7 Oh what I'm
gonna sing cuz Queen d7 would have kept
the got him a gonna happen somehow now
she's winning on a pawns here what is
the count Bishop c5 well played by Elena
wait is it all the Queen Oh green Gianna
take on 87 I'm so excited by this game
keep still good throw another queen 85
do something here we go know that drops
the Queen she wants to meet him John
goodness oh my gosh oh man John sees the
apostle tactics and he misses the mate
don't go anywhere and he doesn't even
react how do you not react malady not
chest ache your head how do you make no
sounds okay we just gotta win this game
and in no time she's gonna witness him
yesterday he doesn't even move he loses
a game let me check mate and look at him
you don't know if he made it her on e7
or if he missed a mate on e7 do we think
he it's like widget which saw is that
saw to where everythings tape-record it
sorry if I spoil the movie account so
long ago too bad but no I mean
everything is pre-recorded so is this
was happening with John he just took a
video or earlier and were just playing
bad sometimes he aligns with what's
happening over the board but other times
yeah other times there's a Miss
misalignment I mean the guys just he
just doesn't react he bought and check
me every time I blunder check me I'm
just furious it's crazy I mean I I would
be throwing I would not have a mouse
left in my apartment out for that but
John takes a sip of his coffee man may
man next game oh my gosh and man man man
next game I didn't seem take a sip of
coffee yeah I was proverbially saying he
took a sip but I wasn't actually saying
it specific coffee robbers sorry Daniel
you want to fool me Mommy okay okay
so black stole the FI pawn and I think
is going to be happy with the outcome
I'm impressed with Elena's feed in the
post section she and that's not till
she's winning games she's playing well
and she's spending on demand she's
playing extremely fast the problem here
is you know if it was maybe one more
point she got that would at least um no
he's normally tough I think the road was
hanging for a PID so because the MU King
g8 was played so quickly my time I
really read you a wait isn't that a free
Brooke wait okay now there
not a detective to check on the king a3
is probably her intention to create a
passed pawn and isn't flex just up a
pawn here
she is and let me tell you something
Robert if she wins this game in the next
45 seconds yeah I'm not saying it's
gonna happen but mathematically oh if
you somehow win wins with two seconds
left in the match John sacking the
bishop he's completely lost here you see
the belts fastened ladies and gentlemen
yep the Queen at four so maybe one is
winning that was a nice fine I was
trying to figure out how to stop this
all and John trying to bleed was much
clock as he can because if there's over
a minute left
that's the divider line I guess and he's
doing a good job here because he's roof
b7 attacking the bishop Elena's still
winning but he keeps harassing that
bishop bishop f8 I guess Bishop FA just
go back yeah Bridget rook c8 and then
like you know the rook goes Mike G over
back to c7 but this is actually becoming
annoying yeah this week a variant of
Queen age six oh my god there was me I
think Oh Queen each six of rookie hey
that wasn't there was a meeting attack
Bishop f8 I guess black defense but now
it's it's a perpetual I'm afraid oh man
what a defense by John dude John is this
the man he's a unbeatable Queen CA wins
for white actually there yeah it's funny
because Queen c1 the bishop and he's not
thinking about that side the board ecigs
the only would save black right now is a
queen blunder
yeah we're just leaving the f2 pawn
hanging engage check this might be at
this rate the last game in the since
match King takes c3 keep it going Eason
6 John stopping Queen f2 a great move
actually should take this - yup in Queen
c7 there's Bishop c5 yeah Bishop d4 ok
our King back and a three and take Oh
filthy a little check look at that look
I was like winning that was evil man
wait but is actually isn't black almost
winning here yeah but John and John is
almost on time
I wasn't looking at the clock I was
looking to board here I'm looking at
John oh there's gotta be that's on me
how does he see for goodness oh my gosh
there was a mate for him and I think the
time was up I don't know but I think the
time maybe to us he one second left
John allows himself meet the smallest
tiniest smile in the world that is just
crazy it was a checkmate for Alina I did
look at look like as a teammate and then
all of a sudden John gets to deliver
checkmate goodness oh nothing nothing
now that comes I mean the final game of
the mesh and fittingly we have another
slot that Robert was just a B that was
the last result you expected White was
the one you know black was the one
hunting hunting hunting all of a sudden
what a maid seriously there was no mate
I'm c3 I can't believe it's there just
had to be something everywhere in that
game line yet the King marched all the
way to g1 trying to deliver a checkmate
except checkmate was delivered to it
first mmm-hmm crazy okay no nice things
if 3x the fish will be protected after
rook takes a three wow wow wow what am I
in Man Man Man Man Man Man Man and then
women that man oh god oh my gosh who
this will definitely go into our
collection of favorite moments in this
match and there have been so many of
them I'm trying to evaluate this match
because yeah as we wind down here and
we'll get the players on for an
interview afterwards so even when this
game concludes we'll have an interview
ready for everybody but just like it
felt like you know early on Alena had
that two-game lead then John just Cruise
in the three minute portion and I don't
remember which game in particular was
sort of the one that just
you know allowed him to go on that run
but it didn't feel like a Lina was
necessary getting outplayed and
something if she was but it wasn't like
this one side of the fair that we've
seen someone other John's matches yeah I
mean for example you know the John's
match against Eddie at some point said
he's just kind of lost the thread really
nothing Oh Elena against Eddie yeah I'm
in 30 lost who did John sweep in the
penultimate Greg right yeah Greg and
before that was Lawrence and right I was
the truest my bed so John against Greg
is the match I was referring to but a
lien against Eddie was the same Oh
rookie five by the way they're finishing
him off immediately but looks like
Elena's gonna win a nice game but yeah I
mean here oliynyk was always in the game
John just calmer and time pressure
better inside pressure and those small
advantages those small victories
accumulated but an amazing match and a
final worthy of a final it really was
and John I mean this would be his
closest match and it's still going to be
a three-point win at the very least for
him and he's well he's about to probably
lose this game but knowing John he'll
somehow swindle this out Nick King g6
he's not giving up f55 Oh filthy a night
at seven and coming he's gonna allow her
to checkmate him out gracious what a
what a good sport a gentlemen we'll be
right back with the interviews of the
players so everybody don't go anywhere
for the I am not a GM speeches
championship final brought to you by
chest comm post match interview
[Music]
and as we have both players here you got
to congratulate you both in what was an
exciting match Nalina I'm sorry the
result didn't go your way but John you
were down two points after the five
minute portion and then you came back
and swept the three-minute portion so
what changed in like do you do something
during the break that changed your
mindset yeah and first of all I want to
say thank you to Alina for a very
hard-fought match I definitely knew this
was not gonna be a an easy match
thanks Jess calm as well for for hosting
this event I had a lot of fun and I
think the twitch viewers enjoyed it
YouTube viewers as well yeah it was for
me mainly a mental shifts I felt like a
boxer who was afraid to let their hands
fly in the 5+1 and I just told myself on
break that I need to start just playing
natural moves and play my game that I
know I'm capable of so I know it's
cliche but sometimes you just literally
have to tell yourself that and that's
what I did on break unfortunately I got
some momentum in the 3-1 and that pretty
much decided the match mm-hmm well Elena
I gotta ask you the same question from
the opposite side you played some
fantastic games throughout and your
quality of play in the three in one
portion were still very very high what
do you feel like went wrong specifically
or do you feel like John just you know
raised his quality of play or both well
first of all congratulations to John
probably I had to be more careful
because I read on the interview that
John feels the more the most comfortable
in this time controls repass one I don't
know it started with this blonde hair
ninety-two and then and then
unfortunately started some probably
woman instability or something I just
couldn't stop losing I mean III felt
that everything goes wrong with this
points I mean yeah I I should have just
come down probably if I would have some
couple of seconds minutes to countdown
and then maybe to make a drawer sound
just to stop this because I think I lost
like six seven games in there or
something like that yes six games there
yeah yeah so so that was that was of
course a mistake from like my site and
John when your side you know that game
where Alina did plunder this 92 it
seemed like you changed your opening so
you were getting tough positions and all
of a sudden you went Knights e4 and e5
so during the break between the 5 and 3
min proportion did you look at that line
a little bit
yeah so I looked at my slob prep and I
you know as has happened in some of
these matches I felt like I got
completely outplayed in the openings so
I knew I had to destroy up some lines
and yeah I looked at a file I created
probably about 15 years ago now and I
fortunately was able to find this 'if
I've idea which i think is the key for
black getting counter play there because
in the first time control I played 96
Andolini just squeezed me so it wasn't a
perfect solution but I do feel like that
changed the momentum I was also trying
this check benoni in one really crazy
game and the five plus one that I think
could have gone either way but yeah that
once I got that win under my belt the
first win and the 3+1 I felt like things
could potentially fall into place for me
and yeah to Elena's point I mean it's
very tough in these matches when the win
for you is like a direct loss for your
opponent and vice versa and when the
wind starts stacking in one one
direction or the other we've seen the
momentum shifts so fast and sometimes
not come back and I feel like that's
just what happened and yeah had she won
a game or two in the 3+1 I mean bullets
I I was minus one I think so yeah it was
really that's just that one time control
well explains and I have the same
question for both of you you know I'll
start with you and I know both of you
are too nice and humble but you know
this is a chance to to say like it is
both of you played like monsters
throughout olena my question is what was
your proudest moment throughout all of
the matches is there one game move match
that stands out to you and where you
really felt like you showed your true
strengths I mean it was every match but
what are you most proud of
[Music]
honestly when I saw the pairings I saw
that that would be a success if I go
through the first round
so I would say that this win was
probably the most important for me as
that was just the first time I've ever
played this speech championship
hopefully not lost and I I think that
that was the most important for me and
as for the move I am proud of this Queen
b6 against Coleman in the first game
that's something none of us will forget
John actually reference sorry today I
actually referenced that move during the
show because our daily question was what
was your favorite moment of this whole
event I mentioned that Queen b6 move
because it was so nice but John what
about on your end okay I kind of want to
say Queenie 1 checkmate in that crazy
time scramble yes Ricky 7 against
Lawrence Trent was a very nice move
involving a knight Fork I really liked
that game right remember that yeah yeah
I mean that game in that you just
referenced John though again Selena that
was such a crazy game we were on the
edge of our seats and especially because
the game before that you blundered
checkmate on e7 yeah and how do you not
react to anything because you didn't
move a muscle
despite wondering checking the clip in
the chat right before we did this last
interview right and someone labelled the
clip John Bartholomew so yeah hahaha but
honestly I felt like in the bullets I
was if I just played along games and ran
out the clock I I knew I was gonna win
provided I didn't let it get too far out
of hand so that was such a long ending
even if I had lost that I I would have
been totally ok well yeah I mean the
same thing even though there was some
time left on the clock I knew that if I
just played normal games probably the
time was gonna take care of itself
well congratulations to John amazing
matches Alina it was a real pleasure to
to commentate this match yeah it was a
fantastic sharing by you both and we're
very appreciative because you both have
so many fans in fact we were asking the
chat earlier
who everybody was rooting for it is
pretty much a 50/50 split with John
having his loyal faithful Amina seems
like you've gained a ton of fans so we
hope that's not the last time we see I'm
sure pretty much positive it will not be
so we lost our screaming yeah
yeah you got to start streaming away not
me you can do both at the same time but
I'm like I said I'm sure you'll be
invited back to more events you two were
really just class action routes such
kind of people and playing amazing chess
that kept the fans in the edge of their
seat so I do want to thank you profusely
just one more time so really thank you
guys so much
yeah yeah it was huge pleasure to play
this event thank you guys we'll let you
two go I know you're probably tired from
this match but we'll let you off there
so thank you again and like I said so
many fans for both of you well we have
this tournament wrapped up it's in the
books we see that the winner is John
Bartholomew the YouTube legend right
he's kind of like the og of chess
content on the interwebs and well hey
guys it's not just John it's I am now
Jim speechless champion winner that's
right rolls right off the tongue doesn't
it I think I'll adopt that I like BOTS
dalam you though that was pretty good
one he doesn't react how was it possible
it's insane it literally with elk at
this time he's gonna have at least a
smile at least a frown at least a shake
of the head but no just a sip of the
coffee and maybe just moves a centimeter
that is the most so we get out of mr.
Bartholomew mr. Bartholomew I don't
drink coffee but maybe I need to start
drinking his brand of coffee because
whatever it is it keeps him so calm and
John is such a strong player he's so
solid even in moments where we were
saying vision looks bad and Elina had
many good positions he just never
collapsed and you said this from the
very first matchup John Bartholomew
never beats himself and that is exactly
why he won this match and Alena she kind
of went on tilt in that three minute
portion she's some good positions she in
the first game things didn't go her way
and that
that kind of spiraled out of control but
kudos to her she won the five-minute
portion and the bullet portion she and
she won two out of three time controls
that's right and well all of the matches
air at each and every one including this
final played by both of these players is
a treat to watch they proved themselves
not only you know as great blitz players
but they played some incredible gains
from just a classical chess perspective
objectively speaking were amazing
combinations and of course they were not
the only ones to do that it's that time
where all of the matches have finished
I wish there would be many more and I'm
sure that similar events will be held
again I'm sure this very event will be
held again but I had an absolute blast
and I'm sad that it's come to an end but
the final was indeed a very fitting one
it was a really special event I'm also
pretty upset that it's over because it
has been such a great time compensating
alongside you and earlier along with
video drop team as well as levy Grossman
we had him on for one show but I just
wanted IMS are SuperDuper strong chess
players and they don't get the same
airtime and that makes sense because in
most sports or games the best people in
the world they get most their time okay
got it but this was such a fun event and
just like newer players for me to calm
down I knew so much common to have seen
players I don't know to expect from them
seeing them go down to the wire like
Elena's match against Kristoff and
Teddy's match against Dani and Teddy's
match against against levy like there
were some really fun matchups along the
way that I will never forget so you know
Danya it is that time it's been such a
fun fun event covering alongside you
here and like was I got to thank all the
fans all the people who are still here
with us the 7,000 of you on Twitch and
also those of you on youtube and
wherever else you're watching thank you
so much chess is growing in chess is
becoming Crees lee popular thanks to
people like you Danya thanks these
players and you Robert we're at each
other I wouldn't choose you are the best
in the business and it's been an
absolute pleasure and thank you to the
fans from from me as well you guys are
amazing this community is like no other
so we really appreciate it
can we get one
more impression but can you do it JB
impression he won we got a you got a
sign-off from the JB impression alright
guys first of all I'd like to thank
Alena that was a great match guys thank
you to the fans guys and yeah I guess
match the match one my way man man man
and I'm just gonna keep drinking my
coffee and enjoy my Saturday and enjoy
your Saturday as well guys bye everybody
see ya everybody
[Music]
you